et la première question va être posée
par Monsieur Charles de Courson pour le
groupe liotte
[Applaudissements]
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues
ma question s'adresse à Monsieur Gabriel
Attal ministre de l'action et des
comptes publics
monsieur le ministre la remise carburant
passera de 30 à 10 centimes à compter de
demain pour disparaître au premier
janvier 2023 quant à la remise dans les
stations totales elle passera demain de
20 centimes à 10 centimes pour
disparaître également à compter du 1er
janvier 2023 ainsi toutes choses égales
par ailleurs le prix du litre de
carburant pourrait à nouveau dépasser
largement les deux euros début 2023
or dimanche dernier sur BFM TV le
porte-parole du gouvernement a annoncé
qu'une aide ciblée prendrait le relais
du dispositif de remise carburant à
compter du 1er janvier 2023 mais ne
concernerait que 11 à 12 millions de
personnes quant à vous-même monsieur le
ministre vous avez esquissé sur LC
quelques critères d'éligibilité je cite
c'était devrait être conditionné au fait
de travailler et d'avoir des revenus
d'activité d'avoir une voiture et un
numéro de carte grise et d'être dans des
catégories populaires ou de classe
moyenne c'est-à-dire des gens qui ont du
mal à joindre les deux veaux fermés les
guillemets
alors Monsieur le Ministre ma question
est toute simple
écartez-vous à l'exception de certains
territoires d'outre-mer la fixation
administrative des prix du carburant et
pourriez-vous préciser à la
représentation nationale le contenu de
ce nouveau dispositif son coûtent et ses
modalités pratiques de mise en œuvre
merci beaucoup mon cher collègue la
parole est à Monsieur Gabriel Attal
ministre délégué chargé des comptes
publics
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Charles de Courson depuis près d'un an à
la faveur d'abord de la reprise
économique poste covid puis de la guerre
en Ukraine les prix du pétrole se sont
envolés au niveau mondial et partout
dans le monde les prix de l'essence ont
très fortement augmenté et dès le
premier jour nous avons fait le choix en
France de protéger les Français les
automobilistes face à cette augmentation
des prix d'abord avec une indemnité
inflation qu'on touchait 38 millions de
Français ensuite avec le dispositif de
la ristourne carburant dont vous avez
rappelé qu'il doit
perdre en voilure à partir de demain et
s'arrêter à la fin de l'année ce
dispositif il aura permis sur toute la
durée de l'année 2022 une économie
moyenne pour un auto mobiliste français
de 120 euros auquel ça s'ajoute 40 euros
pour la remise totale pour ceux qui se
sont approvisionnés dans des stations
totales nous avons assumé cette aide
parce qu'il est nécessaire de protéger
nos concitoyens mais nous l'avons
toujours assumé avec franchise parce que
la réalité est votre groupe le groupe
liote l'a rappelé régulièrement dans les
débats budgétaires c'est que derrière
l'automobiliste qui fait le plein il y a
le contribuable qui paye et en
l'occurrence le contribuable des années
à venir et donc ce dispositif nous
l'avons toujours dit à vocation à vos
vocation à être ciblées et temporaire
cibler dans le temps c'est 8 milliards
d'euros dans l'année 2022 qui auront été
dépensés au titre de la ristourne ce cas
annoncé le président de la République
c'est qu'à compter de l'année 2023 nous
irons vers un dispositif plus ciblé vous
avez indiqué certaines modalités que
j'ai et ce qui c'est il s'agit des
modalités qui avaient été prévues pour
l'indemnité carburant travailleur cette
aide pour les gros rouleurs ou gros
bosseurs que nous avons imaginé cet été
nous avons prévu dans le projet de loi
de finances une enveloppe d'un milliard
600 millions d'euros pour un dispositif
de soutien au pouvoir d'achat face à
l'envolée des prix de l'énergie l'an
prochain et nous aurons l'occasion dans
les prochains jours les prochaines
semaines de définir concrètement les
critères et les modalités de ce
dispositif une seule boussole continuer
à protéger les Français sans laisser nos
comptes publics dérapés et donc les
impôts de demain augmenter merci
monsieur le ministre monsieur de Courson
[Applaudissements]
notre groupe lyode comme vous l'avez
rappelé d'ailleurs a toujours plaidé
pour concentrer les aides sur nos
concitoyens les plus en difficulté et de
ne pas prendre des mesures générales qui
ruinent les finances publiques donc nous
nous réjouissons que vous soyez revenu à
la position initiale du gouvernement de
Juillet mais pas sa position finale
cependant vos éléments de réponse
monsieur le ministre manque de clarté
merci beaucoup la question suivante va
être posée pendant par Madame Laure La
Valette pour le groupe rassemblement
national
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre l'humanisme ça n'est
pas le bon sentiment si je choisissais
cette voix elle ferait basculer le pays
voici ce que déclaré Macron en 2018 au
sujet de l'Aquarius finalement débarqué
en Espagne en faisant 7 fois Coster
l'océan Viking dans le port militaire de
Toulon pour le soustraire à la vue de
tous vous faites basculer le pays à
l'heure où tous les peuples européens
dis STOP à l'immigration massive la
France se pose comme le pays qui
encourage la clandestinité et pousse de
pauvres gens à risquer leur vie le
rapport 2021 de l'agence Frontex est
sans équivoque les migrants venus de
libides déclarent constamment vérifier
la présence des ONG avant leur départ
expliquant je cite quand l'absence de
ces navires beaucoup refusent de partir
les trafiquants d'êtres humains ont
gagné les ONG sont leurs complices
idéologiques et désormais vous aussi
vous attaquez l'Italie qui submergeait
depuis 10 ans n'en veut plus et ce à
leur même que son peuple la signifiait
dans les urnes il y a encore un mois que
dites-vous madame la Premier ministre à
vos amis de Malte qui n'en veulent pas
non plus rien à la Tunisie dans les
ports étaient les plus proches au moment
du sauvetage rien et que dites-vous à la
Norvège dont le pavillon permet à cette
ONG de naviguer impunément toujours rien
madame la Premier ministre vous ne
faites rien laissant de rétention
explosent vous expulsez personne nos
policiers travaillent dans le vide d'une
justice qui ne suit plus les préfectures
débordent tandis qu' anciens ministres
et préfet des fils dans les médias pour
décrire l'inimaginable votre politique
s'est accueillir et répartir le
rassemblement national lui veut secourir
et reconduire ma question madame borne
l'océan Viking est actuellement à
Marseille allez-vous enfin faire votre
travail et mettre sous scellé ce navire
ou allez vous continuer de subir je vous
remercie
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Gérald Darmanin
ministre de l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
merci madame la Présidente
mesdames et messieurs députés madame la
députée
finalement une question est simple si
vous étiez responsabilité
auriez-vous laissé mourir ces 44 enfants
[Applaudissements]
je vais vous donner la parole Madame La
Valette
il me manque 3 3 secondes
à la terre entière et dites aujourd'hui
l'inverse de ce que vous affirmiez hier
permettez-moi de faire le point sur
votre travail chaos Stade de France
mensonge d'État sur les supporters
anglais explosion des atteintes aux
personnes pire chiffre sécurité depuis
des décennies
humiliation par un imam étranger abandon
de Mayotte crise migratoire dans la
Manche et accostage de bateau de
migrants dans le sud dans une démocratie
normale on aurait des
monsieur
le ministre de l'Intérieur
[Applaudissements]
merci Madame Présidente je constate
madame la députée que vous répondez pas
à cette question simple que tout homme
et que tout femme politique doit
résoudre dans sa tête vous n'êtes pas
prêt au responsabilités madame
parce que vous ne répondez pas à cette
question simple de la décision politique
une décision politique ne vit pas dans
le monde incroyable des réunions du
Front national entre personnes qui sont
d'accord entre personnes qui disent
qu'il faut qu'il retourne de là où ils
viennent madame la question la question
de la vie politique c'est que la seule
querelle qui vaille c'est celle de
l'homme ou alors vous auriez laissé
mourir ses enfants madame la députée
et la vérité madame la députée
la vérité m'avait été c'est que nous
avons secouru des femmes et les enfants
que malheureusement l'Italie n'a pas
voulu secourir la vérité madame la
députée c'est que nous avons fait preuve
d'humanisme quand vous faites de la
politique politicienne la vérité madame
la députée
c'est que vous n'êtes pas apte au
pouvoir parce que vous n'êtes pas
d'apprendre des décisions difficiles en
regardant les Français dans les yeux et
je m'endorgueille madame la députée que
soit cette majorité qui se pouvoir pour
sauver ses enfants là avec vous on sait
ce qui serait devenu
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Yannick
chenevas pour le groupe Renaissance
merci
merci madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues
avant toute chose je voudrais évidemment
conforter ce que je viens de dire le
ministre de l'intérieur car mal nommé
les choses c'est ajouter au malheur du
monde écrivait Albert Camus
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
monsieur le ministre le 11 novembre
dernier la France permettait à 234
hommes femmes enfants de ne pas périr en
mer après 20 jours des rances et le
refus de l'un de nos partenaires
européens d'appliquer le droit
international
cette décision obéit à trois devoirs
devoir de sanctions
envers ceux qui sont des vautours des
mers passeurs qui s'enrichissent de la
misère humaine
devoir de fermeté qui correspond à un
objectif
constitutionnel celui de l'ordre public
celui de la cohésion nationale du
maintien de l'édifice républicain de
voir de fermeté encore et de voir de
fraternité un principe constitutionnel
constitutif de notre République de notre
état de français
qui figure sur le fronton de nos mairies
de nos écoles
j'observe que cette décision procède
d'un manquement un manquement un autre
devoir celui de la réciprocité si
certains ne restent ne respectent pas
leur signature la France sonore de
respecter la sienne monsieur le ministre
pouvez-vous nous préciser
quelles sont les actions menées par la
DGSI auprès de ces personnes
quels seront les mécanismes de
reconduite des individus qui ne seraient
pas éligibles à demander l'asile je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur Gérald
Darmanin ministre de l'Intérieur et les
outre-mer merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Député en effet le 11
novembre dernier
l'État français a demandé à le navire
qui demandait aide selon le constat du
droit international de la mer
appareillée militaire de Toulon les 234
personnes à bord ont été accueillis aux
port militaire de Toulon ils ont d'abord
subi un examen médical puis ensuite un
entretien chacun d'entre eux avec les
services de la DGSI puis un entretien
avec l'ofra le fils de protection des
personnes qui demandent où vous le savez
l'asile sur le territoire de la
République sur ces 234 personnes au
moment où je vous parle l'ensemble des
démarches se sont pas terminées 44 ont
été reconnus mineurs
60 peuvent demander l'asile notamment
des Syriens des Soudanais des érythréens
44 se voit désormais un refus opposé à
leur demande d'asile dans la zone
d'attente qui est aujourd'hui celle de
la presqu'île de Gien comme vous le
savez pour les personnes qui peuvent
demander l'asile ce qui ne présume pas
du fond évidemment de leur demande nous
allons permettre le répartition de ces
personnes sur le territoire européen 11
pays que je souhaite remercier et cités
dans leur présentation nationale accepte
de les relocaliser l'Allemagne la
Bulgarie la Croatie la Finlande
l'Irlande la Lituanie le Luxembourg
Malte la Norvège le Portugal et la
Roumanie ce qui provient que la solution
est européenne
[Applaudissements]
pour les personnes qui se voient refuser
leur demande d'asile c'est 40 personnes
seront évidemment reconduites dès que
leur état de santé pour certains d'entre
eux le permettront dans leur territoire
national j'ai déjà pris à la demande de
la première ministre du président de la
République contact des IR avec mes
homogues étrangers pour que ces
reconduites à la frontière puissent se
faire évidemment dans les temps les plus
courts possibles notamment d'ici la fin
de la zone d'attente dans une vingtaine
de jours merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre la parole est à Madame Annie
Genval pour le groupe les républicains
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à madame la Première ministre
en un mois les atteintes à la laïcité
ont doublé dans les établissements
scolaires elle concerne dans la majorité
des cas le port de tenue et de signes
religieux
face à cette réalité il y a deux
attitudes possibles ce borné a des
réponses techniques alors que clairement
une circulaire ne suffira pas ou
affronter cette offensive politique qui
est à l'œuvre sur les réseaux sociaux et
qui conduit les adolescents à contester
la primauté de nos principes
républicains il faut dire ce que l'on
voit surtout il faut toujours ce qui est
plus difficile disait PEGI voir ce que
l'on voit aujourd'hui comment 1989 avec
l'affaire des trois collégiennes voilées
de Creil la situation impose une parole
politique forte il avait fallu attendre
Jacques Chirac en 2004 pour qu'une loi
se dresse et protège l'école de
l'islamisme aujourd'hui à nouveau cette
idéologie relance son offensive en
utilisant le vêtement comme un étendard
et des adolescents comme des portes
drapeau les enseignants comme les élèves
et leurs parents ont besoin d'un
discours politique tenu au plus haut
niveau madame même la première ministre
je m'adresse à vous parce que vous avez
dédié votre nomination à Matignon aux
petites filles en leur disant d'aller au
bout de leurs rêves vous êtes au
rendez-vous de la responsabilité madame
la première minute êtes-vous prête à
dire qu'en France comment on ira ou en
Afghanistan tout vêtement qui affiche la
soumission des filles n'a pas sa place à
l'école
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur pas peine
ministre de l'éducation nationale et de
la jeunesse madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la députée Annie Genval
vous le savez vous avez raison les
chiffres de signalement des atteintes à
la laïcité que je me suis engagé à
publier mensuellement
signal une augmentation pour le mois
d'octobre une augmentation liée à trois
phénomènes le premier c'est l'influence
des réseaux sociaux avec la
multiplication depuis la mi-septembre
des challenges des défis qui sont lancés
par des personnes qui ne veulent ni de
bien aux élèves ni de biens écoles ni de
bien à la République nous avons
évidemment peu de moyens d'agir
juridiquement sur les réseaux sociaux
mais nous travaillons
à augmenter et à améliorer la modération
sur les réseaux sociaux en lien avec les
personnes concernées le deuxième
phénomène c'est l'hommage à Samuel Paty
qui s'est malheureusement accompagné
comme l'an dernier de contestation le
troisième élément c'est la vigilance
accrue qui de tous les personnels qui
font de mieux en mieux pour faire
remonter les atteintes à la laïcité et
c'est bien l'objectif que nous
poursuivons avec les données mensuelles
que j'ai indiquées c'est pourquoi nous
avons publié une circulaire qui est très
claire qui vise à sanctionner
systématiquement et des sanctions sont
prises elles ont été prises récemment
depuis la rentrée renforcer la
protection et le soutien au personnel
appuyez l'action des chefs
d'établissement et renforcer la
formation je vous le redis notre
boussole très ferme et très clair
la loi de 2004 c'est principe nous
permettent de gérer l'ensemble des
situations nous agissons madame la
députée nous agissons avec discernement
nous agissons avec fermeté et nous
continuerons à le faire je vous remercie
madame Genval merci merci monsieur le
ministre monsieur le ministre vous
décrivez nous ce que nous voulons c'est
une réponse politique forte tenue au
plus haut niveau madame la Première
ministre je regrette que vous esquiviez
cette réponse on n'a pas besoin d'une
réponse administrative on a besoin d'une
réponse politique je vous remercie
la parole est à madame Isabelle rouge
pour le groupe horizon merci madame la
Présidente ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'éducation
nationale et de la jeunesse monsieur le
ministre à l'heure des polémiques en
tout genre je tiens à saluer votre
décision de rendre à nouveau les maths
obligatoire au lycée et d'ajouter des
heures d'enseignement dont nos élèves
ont besoin pour progresser comme le
disait Jean-Marie Souriau mathématicien
français les maths ça prend le relais
dans les situations où l'intelligence
habituelle est en panne
les chaussures sont un instrument pour
marcher les maths sont un instrument
pour penser on peut marcher sans
chaussures mais on va moins loin
la France n'a pas rougir de son niveau
en maths elle est une nation
d'excellence dans ce domaine et selon le
classement de Shanghai nos
établissements français sont classés 18e
parmi les 100 premiers mondiaux les
mathématiques sont au cœur du monde
moderne et conditionnent de nombreux
métiers de demain elles sont nécessaires
en informatique aérospatiale nucléaire
et participe au bon fonctionnement de
notre vie quotidienne il est inutile de
rappeler au combien les mathématiques
sont importantes pour le bon
fonctionnement de notre société de plus
alors qu'ils deviennent nécessaires de
renforcer notre culture mathématique et
que nos élèves considèrent cette matière
comme inattractive ils sont aujourd'hui
encore trop nombreux à quitter le
système scolaire sans détenir les acquis
nécessaires dans ce domaine le conseil
est clair 25% des élèves n'ont pas le
niveau attendu en maths à l'issue de la
classe de 3e un constat plus préoccupant
encore pour les élèves qui s'orientent
vers le lycée professionnel ou 70%
d'entre eux ont un niveau trop faible en
mathématiques monsieur le ministre
comment rendre à nouveau attractif cette
matière aux yeux de nos élèves pour
préparer les métiers des citoyens de
demain
d'autre part vous connaissez mon
attachement aux questions d'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes en nous
sommes aujourd'hui confrontés à une
autre inégalité scolaire les jeunes
filles ne choisissent pas les
mathématiques à l'école et son exclu
elles sont 46% étudiées encore les maths
en terminale tout enseignement confondus
et 26% à les choisir comme spécialité
comment rompre cette disparité entre
filles et garçons et rendre les
mathématiques attractifs en celles-ci je
vous remercie je vous remercie la parole
est à Monsieur pas pendy ministre de
l'éducation nationale et de la jeunesse
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
Isabelle rouge vous avez raison le
paradoxe français et le suivant la
France est une grande nation de
mathématiques avec une longue tradition
d'excellence 13 médailles field et un
niveau moyen en mathématiques qui s'est
détérioré depuis plusieurs décennies en
réalité et qui pose des problèmes
évidents en l'entrée en 6e à l'entrée en
seconde et dans les études de supérieur
face à cela j'ai décidé en effet de
réintroduire à la rentrée prochaine une
heure et demie de mathématiques
obligatoire pour le tronc commun en
classe de première pour les élèves qui
ne suivent pas la spécialité mais ce
n'est pas suffisant nous poursuivons par
un plan mathématique général qui va de
la classe qui va du primaire jusqu'à la
terminale qui passe par la meilleure
formation des professeurs des écoles qui
passent par des groupes réduits à
l'entrée en 6e à l'issue des tests
d'évaluation par la promotion des clubs
de maths au collège par des modules de
mathématiques en seconde et par leur
ennemi donc de mathématiques dans le
tronc commun des élèves de première et
puis nous avons un sujet qui me tient
particulièrement à coeur c'est celui de
l'égalité fille garçon pour les études
scientifiques et particulièrement des
mathématiques et là nous devons avoir
une politique volontariste j'ai fixer
comme objectif à l'issue du quinquennat
la parité fille garçon pour les filières
mathématiques du lycée et à l'entrée au
dans les études supérieures ça on va le
faire par une politique volontariste
menée au niveau des chefs
d'établissement et des enseignants pour
qu'ils incitent les filles à choisir les
spécialités scientifiques et notamment
les mathématiques en particulier à
l'entrée en terminale et pour l'option
de mathématiques expert nous devons
avoir une politique extrêmement
volontariste en la matière je vous
remercie monsieur le ministre la parole
est à madame la Présidente panneau
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre vous n'avez plus aucun
secret pour nous Emmanuel Macron n'a
qu'une obsession pour son second mandat
la case des retraites et c'est vous qui
la missionné pour cela le Président nous
a prévenu il ne partira pas sans avoir
repoussé à 64 ans l'âge de départ à la
retraite et saccager notre système par
répartition vous n'avez pas le mandat du
peuple pour faire cette réforme 8
Français sur dix y sont opposés non vous
êtes les commis des intérêts privés qui
vous ont élus et attendre leur retour
sur investissement en 2019 nous avons
fait échouer une première fois votre
réforme indigne cette fois pour mieux
faire diversion vous nous parlez encore
de grandes concertations mais nous ne
sommes pas dupe vous ne comptez pas
bouger d'un iota samedi dernier les
sénateurs vous ont servi sur un plateau
le report de l'âge de départ à la
retraite à 64 ans avec 43 annuités en
introduisant dans le projet de loi de
financement de la Sécurité social
pratique une mesure adoptée en catimini
pas de mouvement social un petit 49,3 et
le tour serait joué avec vous la réforme
des retraites passeraient en force mes
abats bruits en macronie tout est bon
pour faire 8 milliards d'économies peu
importe si le Conseil d'orientation des
retraites ni toute urgence et réfute je
cite le discours d'une dynamique non
contrôlée des dépenses peu importe si
cette réforme coûterait des milliards en
pension d'invalidité indemnités maladies
et chômage peu importe si un quart des
hommes les plus pauvres sont déjà morts
avant 62 ans oui seuls les riches
pourront vivre en paix en macronie pour
les autres vous ne reculez pas l'âge de
la retraite vous avancez l'âge de la
mort alors pourquoi faire une réforme
dont personne ne veut madame la Première
ministre vous voit la prévenu un seul
geste et vous nous trouverez dans la rue
dès le lendemain un seul geste et nous
vous ferons battre en retraite
je vous remercie la parrotte est à
madame la Première ministre
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
Mathilde de panneau madame la Présidente
Mathilde panot
il est parfois utile de revenir en
arrière et de rappeler quelques faits
que vous persistez à vouloir ignorer
alors permettez-moi d'en revenir à la
chronologie
le président de la République a été
réélu pour un second mandat le dimanche
24 avril 2022
des élections législatives ont eu lieu
les 12 et 19 juin de cette même année
j'ai pour ma part comme chacun ici était
élu député et enfin
j'ai prononcé ma déclaration de
politique générale ici même le 6 juillet
dernier
c'était il y a quelques mois mais pour
paraphraser une chanson populaire pour
vous c'était il y a un siècle une
éternité car manifestement votre mémoire
les a peut-être inconsciemment effacé
oh madame la Présidente panneau au cours
de ces différents moments démocratiques
les choses ont été dites avec la plus
grande transparence aux Français et je
vous dirai même que ça n'a pas toujours
été facile il aurait peut-être été plus
simple plus confortable de ne rien dire
il aurait peut-être été plus populaire
de dire que l'on pourrait revenir à un
âge de départ à 60 ans plus populaire
c'est vrai mais aussi plus démagogique
et cela n'a échappé à personne et
surtout pas aux Français qui n'ont
d'ailleurs pas élu votre grand leader à
la présidence de la République
[Applaudissements]
comme ils n'ont pas élu Madame Le Pen
non ils ont fait le choix délire le
président de la République et de donner
une majorité à ceux qui portaient son
projet
[Applaudissements]
donc oui je vous le confirme il y aura
une réforme des retraites et oui cette
réforme entrera en vigueur à l'été 2023
et depuis des semaines des discussions
ont lieu avec les partenaires sociaux
avec tous les partenaires sociaux pour
préparer cette réforme oui Olivier du
soft dialogue travail
approfondi les différents points pour
construire une réforme qui assure la
pérennité de notre système de retraite
pour construire une réforme juste qui
tienne compte de la diversité des vies
professionnelles alors en effet
parallèlement les sénateurs ont avancé
des propositions même si elles ne
viennent pas de notre majorité nous
regarderons ces propositions avec
attention et mesdames et messieurs les
députés pour assurer l'équilibre des
différents régimes de retraite et donc
la pérennité de notre système de
retraite par répartition nous allons
devoir progressivement
travailler un peu plus longtemps ce
décalage de l'âge permettra une
augmentation des pensions on ne
travaillera pas davantage pour rien et
oui s'il fallait le redire il ne s'agit
pas de reculer brutalement d'un an de
deux ans ou deux trois ans l'âge de
départ à la retraite mais de les décaler
progressivement de quelques mois chaque
année oui il faut faire cette réforme
pour protéger le niveau de vie des
retraités et nous augmenterons la
pension minimale et oui les salariés qui
ont eu des carrières longues qui ont
donc commencé à travailler plus tôt
continueront à partir plus tôt et oui il
faut tenir compte de la pénibilité de
certains métiers nous allons la prévenir
la compenser et nous construirons un
dispositif plus complet avec les
partenaires sociaux et non nous n'avons
pas de totems c'est l'objet même des
discussions qui ont lieu les impasses
financières sont connus et nous
examinerons tous les leviers pour
dégager des ressources en un mot madame
la Présidente panneau je crois au
travail je crois que nous pouvons sortir
de cette spécificité française avec un
taux d'emploi des seniors le plus bas
d'Europe et ça n'est clairement pas la
responsabilité des salariés les plus
âgés je crois que le travail crée de la
richesse et que cette richesse permet de
préserver et même de faire progresser
notre modèle social donc voilà madame la
Présidente panot tous les sujets sont
ouverts et nos principes sont clairs la
justice l'efficacité la lisibilité de la
réforme et j'aurais l'occasion dans
quelques semaines de revenir devant vous
pour présenter les conclusions des
concertations en cours là encore nous
serons dans la transparence et le
dialogue c'est ma méthode c'est la
méthode du gouvernement nous nous y
tiendrons malgré les raccourcis les
procès d'intention ou la démagogie je
vous remercie
je vous remercie
madame la Présidente
madame la première minute c'est vous en
train de nous confirmer que vous allez
passer en catimini la réforme des
retraites dans le PLFSS que vous étudiez
avec intérêt comme vous venez de le dire
la parole est à Madame violette
spielboot pour le groupe Renaissance
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre de la ville et du logement
il était chef du pôle santé mentale et
Addictologie au centre hospitalier de
Calais il s'appelait Alexandre Klein ses
patients disent de lui qu'il était un
médecin très humain bienveillant et à
l'écoute il a été retrouvé samedi dans
la nuit à Lille sous les gravats de deux
immeubles de la rue Pierre Mauroy
effondré le matin même je tiens ici à
exprimer au nom de la représentation
nationale toutes mes condoléances à sa
famille ses collègues ses proches
l'odeur de poussière flotte encore dans
l'air au numéro 42 et 44 de cette rue
Pierre Mauroy de notre centre-ville
cette rue si symbolique et si chère au
cœur des Lillois ce terrible drame n'est
malheureusement pas sans rappeler celui
de la rue d'Aubagne à Marseille où celui
de la rue de Trévise à Paris et bien
d'autres encore
sans l'alerte donnée par Thibault
Constantin Gaspard ses trois jeunes
étudiants revenus de sortie dans la nuit
de vendredi à samedi que ce serait-il
passé
sans l'intervention immédiate des
Pompiers Sans la réactivité de la police
municipale et nationale de la préfecture
des agents de la mairie et autres forces
spécialisées quelle tragédie encore plus
meurtrière aurions-nous vécu des vies
ont été sauvées par une évacuation bien
organisée mais nous déplorons indisparus
c'est beaucoup trop monsieur le ministre
je tiens une nouvelle fois à vous
remercier pour votre venue rapide à
Lille aux côtés de notre mère sur les
lieux du drame alors après l'effroi
l'inquiétude le recueillement
aujourd'hui viendra désormais le temps
de l'enquête tout sera entrepris pour
comprendre les raisons de cet
effondrement
en parallèle du travail judiciaire vous
venez d'annoncer le lancement d'une
étude sur le bâti du secteur qui sera
confiée au Centre Scientifique et
Technique du Bâtiment nous voulons tous
nous assurer que de telles effondrements
ne puissent merci beaucoup la parole est
à Monsieur Olivier Klein ministre
délégué chargé de la ville et du
logement
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
pilou oui un drame s'est produit à Lille
ce week-end je veux comme vous saluer la
mémoire de la personne décédée dans ce
terrible effondrement et apporter au nom
du gouvernement tout mon soutien à sa
famille et à ses proches je tiens comme
vous à saluer le courage et le sens
civique de ces trois jeunes étudiants
qui ont cette nuit là sauver des vies
j'ai eu l'occasion de les avoir au
téléphone comme un certain nombre
d'autres membres du gouvernement des
samedis et les rencontrer hier et nous
leur devons toute notre reconnaissance
je vais aussi saluer comme vous l'avez
fait la réactivité des services de
secours des services de l'état des
services de la ville qui ont pris
immédiatement la mesure du risque et on
procédé à l'évacuation du bâtiment et
pris un arrêté de péril
éminent et puis je veux aussi saluer
madame la députée votre mobilisation
tout au long du week-end ainsi que de
votre collègue Brigitte Lizo je vous ai
toutes les deux rencontrées hier la
priorité maintenant et bien sûr le
soutien aux personnes sinistrées il
travaille du relogement il est en cours
avec les services de la Ville de Lille
et les services de la préfecture comme
vous l'avez dit le temps est un
investigation celui de l'investigation
judiciaire mais il faudra aussi c'est
mon souhait je l'ai proposé à la mère de
Lille une étude complémentaire que nous
allons confier au CSTB que nous
confinement avec la ville pour que toute
la lumière soit faite et qu'un tel drame
ne puisse pas se reproduire ici comme
ailleurs et puis je vais vous le redire
la mobilisation du gouvernement sur
l'habitat salut même si on ne peut pas à
ce stade qualifier d'insalubre
l'immeuble qui s'est effondré rue Pierre
Mauroy et bien cette mobilisation est
très grande c'est plus de 15000 dossiers
qu'on était confiés à la nappe pour
résorber l'habitat insalubre pendant
l'année 22 c'est 20% de plus que ce qui
avait été fait en 2018 et là aussi cette
mobilisation est complète merci encore
tous mes pensées aux Lillois je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur Hubert
Julien Laferrière pour le groupe
écologiste
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur
il nous a raconté l'enfer qu'il a vécu
en Libye avant de risquer la mort en
traversant la Méditerranée il fait
partie de ces 234 rescapés de l'océan
viking qui avait mes collègues sénateurs
d'après ce qu'il de Giens
après le refus honteux du gouvernement
néo fasciste italien la France se devait
être au rendez-vous et nous l'avons
salué pendant que d'autres adeptes de la
théorie du Grand remplacement aurait
souhaité qu'on les abandonne
mais nous avons pu constater
également de graves dysfonctionnements
dans le cadre de ce qu'on appelle
l'asile aux frontières
les entretiens de Lovecraft se déroulent
dans des tentes avec un manque de
confidentialité totale la traduction se
fait par téléphone les réfugiés sont mal
informés de leurs droits le suivi
psychologique est inexistant des
dysfonctionnements tel monsieur le
ministre que le juste les libertés de la
détention a déjà pris des décisions de
libération de nombre de ces exilés mes
chers collègues ces personnes ne sont
pas des chiffres ce sont bien sûr des
vies humaines et vous connaissez
l'enquête accablante du monde sur le
terrible naufrage du 24 novembre 2001
2021 pardon dans la Manche ou 27
personnes se sont noyées en pleine nuit
pendant des heures sans que les
autorités françaises n'interviennent
n'est-ce pas là le symptôme de ce à quoi
peut mener l'indifférence la
banalisation de la misère et des
discours de l'extrême droite
monsieur le ministre j'ai donc trois
questions pouvez-vous nous assurer que
tout est mis en oeuvre pour que de tels
drames dans la Manche ne se reproduisent
plus
l'océan de Viking ne se restera-t-il
qu'une simple exception à la politique
migratoire menée depuis le 2017
pouvez-vous nous assurer enfin que le
droit d'Asie de ces rescapés sera
respecté et que la France fidèle à ses
valeurs prendra sa pleine et entière
part dans leur accueil je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Gérald Darmanin
ministre de l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
madame la Présidente Mesdames Messieurs
les Députés monsieur le député vous
m'avez posé trois questions je vais
essayer d'y répondre
sur le drame terrible des 27 morts dans
la mer de manche il y a une enquête
judiciaire vous le savez elle est
ouverte la gendarmerie nationale je
crois est saisie
nous avons lu comme vous l'article du
Monde
les autorités maritimes qui
interviennent pour sauver les personnes
dans les autres territoriales françaises
dépendent pas de mon autorité je n'ai
personnellement pas d'informations sur
ce sujet ce qui est certain c'est que
l'accord britannique enfin signait avec
le nouveau gouvernement qui a été nommé
par le roi Balarin d'Angleterre et le
roi d'Angleterre fait que nous avons pu
trouver un accord désormais financier
technique mais aussi humain pour
accompagner non seulement le nord de la
France et le Pas-de-Calais mais
l'Angleterre dans la lutte contre les
passeurs et l'accueil des personnes
migrantes nous devons vous le savez
résoudre des problèmes migratoires dans
la mer de manche par un accord européen
à traiter européen qui prévoit une voie
d'immigration légale en Bretagne et nous
ne sommes pas encore là même si nous
devons y travailler le deuxième sujet
sur l'Océane Viking oui tout est fait
pour accueillir le mieux possible
monsieur le député les deux34 personnes
je veux dire que le juge de liberté des
tensions a pris des sciences sur quatre
personnes et non pas sur deux très
nombreuses personnes comme vous l'avez
évoquée peut-être était quatre de trop
vous avez raison les 44 mineurs ont
d'ailleurs été logés par le Conseil
départemental du Var et je les en
remercie en lien avec madame la
secrétaire d'État je veux signaler qu'en
quelques heures la France vous le savez
a accueilli ce bateau a permis les soins
médicaux
le criblage de la DGSI et l'accueil par
l'OFPRA sans doute dans des conditions
qui sont rapides mais dans des
conditions je crois qu'il faut on aura
la France et merci d'avoir salué
troisièmement effectivement le bateau
SOS Méditerranée et en ce moment dans un
port civil en train d'être inspecter par
les services de l'État et on aura
l'occasion sur de revenir je vous
remercie monsieur le ministre la parole
est à Monsieur au président
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le secrétaire d'État à la mer
chers collègues
depuis le début de cette séance nous
avons pris 1200 respirations 600 d'entre
elles nous les devons aux océans
ces océans sont le berceau de la vie sur
Terre
et pourtant aujourd'hui ils sont menacés
menacés par la convoitise des hommes
menacé pour les ressources minières
minérales qui reposent au fond de ces
océans il y a un peu plus d'une semaine
le président de la République à la COP
27 à Sharm El Sheikh
se déclarait le champion de ces grands
fonds
il nous annonçait vouloir porter partout
le message d'interdiction d'exploiter
ces océans le fond de ces océans
mais ce message ne s'adresse qu'à un
périmètre somme toute limité celui des
eaux internationales dont s'occupe la
IFM
pas un mot sur les aides de la France
pourtant deuxième domaine maritime
mondial
ce cette ze ce domaine maritime mondial
les outre-mer
on représente la grande partie
la Polynésie que je présente à elle
seule représenter près de la moitié de
cette aide
en septembre 2021 lui ICN avait adopté
un moratoire sur l'exploitation des
fonds marins et la France est obtenue
ma question est donc
porter le message d'interdire
l'exploitation des grands fonds pour
l'international c'est bien mais est-ce
qu'on va charliter bien ordonner
commençons par soi-même s'appliquer ces
grands principes aux aides françaises
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Hervé Berville secrétaire des
tâches chargée de la mer merci beaucoup
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
moi taille brotherson d'abord je me
permets vraiment de vous saluer et de
saluer votre engagement au sein
notamment de l'alliance des
parlementaires du Pacifique ainsi que
vos collègues polynésiens notamment le
sénateur
rothsch Fritz pour l'engagement à la
protection des océans
l'annonce du président de la République
à la COP 27 à Charmed cher en Égypte
était très clair c'est une annonce que
seule la France a faite de dire nous
sommes pour l'interdiction totale de
l'exploitation minière dans les grands
fonds marins c'est une annonce qui est
inédite
parce que elle va plus loin que ce que
vous mentionnez tout à l'heure sur le
moratoire qui était proposé qui était
porté par un certain nombre de pays et
par ici par des parlementaires et va
plus loin que la pose de précaution qui
était là aussi portée par un certain
nombre de pays et donc pour répondre
très clairement avec question c'est
interdiction totale de l'interdiction de
l'exploitation minière dans les grands
fonds marins s'applique bien évidemment
et nous allons le porter dans les eaux
internationales en haute mer mais
également dans la ZEE française et donc
il n'y aura pas de licence
d'exploitation pour et bien mener ses
activités qui sont néfastes qui sont
nocives pour nos océans dans la Z2
française on va porter le combat à
l'international ni aujourd'hui ni demain
et ce que vous évoquez c'est au fond les
prochaines étapes et donc nous avons eu
l'occasion de le dire très clairement au
Conseil de la IFM à travers la voix de
l'ambassadeur que je salue pour la
clarté la France va se battre pour
justement faire appliquer ce qu'elle
appliquera dans la Z2 dans toutes les Z2
mais pour l'instant nous n'avons pas les
moyens légaux d'interdire aux autres
pays de pour le faire et donc ce sera un
combat qu'on va mener à l'IFM c'est un
combat que nous avons mené aussi à la
COP15 et bien de Montréal pour dire à
quel point il est essentiel de pas
s'engager dans cette voie de
l'exploitation parce que les dommages
seront irréversibles sur nos océans
seront irréversibles sur la biodiversité
marine et puis c'est aussi un combat
qu'on va continuer à porter en finançant
la recherche la connaissance
scientifique pour monter la fragilité de
il vous reste 10 secondes monsieur le
président
je vous remercie pour cette réponse qui
personnellement me rassure mais quand
tout ça sera mis par écrit je serai
encore plus rassuré
merci madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à madame
la ministre de la transition énergétique
madame la ministre vous avez demandé la
sobriété énergétique aux Français à nos
TPE et PME et bien certains fournisseurs
ont décidé de les y mettre d'office
voici un exemple il y a quelques jours
j'ai inauguré une boulangerie pâtisserie
dans le village de Bouret commun dans
l'Aisne lorsque la direction de cet
établissement qui fonctionne avec un
compteur provisoire à l'énergie limitée
à solliciter tout naturellement auprès
du distributeur réseau un contrat en
offre de marché conformément à la loi du
1er janvier 2016 elle s'est vu répondre
qu'aucun fournisseur d'électricité ne
souhaitait engager de nouveaux contrats
y compris EDF
ce fait devient de plus en plus courant
après avoir pris attache avec les
fournisseurs il semblerait et je cite
que le contexte de crise les risques de
pénurie l'instabilité du marché de
l'électricité ainsi que les fournisseurs
à réduire leur exposition financière en
limitant le nombre de nouveaux clients
entrant dans leur portefeuille il existe
bien le Médiateur de l'énergie compétent
pour résoudre les litiges des
entreprises de moins de 9 salariés lors
de l'exécution de contrats souscrits
mais qu'en est-il si justement il n'y a
aucun contrat signé bon nombre
d'entreprises se voient donc refuser de
nouveaux contrats ou supportent pour les
existants de nouveaux tarifs
inacceptables des entreprises mais aussi
des particuliers se déconnecte du réseau
électrique en s'équipant contraint et
forcé de groupes électrogène polluants
la libéralisation du marché que vous
chérissez tant avec la complicité de la
Commission européenne n'a absolument pas
les Français bien au contraire que
comptez-vous faire au vu de l'urgence
pour résoudre ce problème je vous
remercie je vous remercie
de la transition énergétique
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
dragon vous le savez nous vivons la plus
grave crise énergétique depuis près de
50 ans cette crise elle a un impact
important sur le prix de l'énergie pour
les Français les entreprises et les
collectivités locales et comme vous le
savez nous sommes un des gouvernements
qui a le plus fait pour protéger le
pouvoir d'achat des Français la
compétitivité des entreprises et les
services publics des collectivités
locales vous mentionnez la situation
d'un boulanger qui n'a pas de contrat
aujourd'hui vous avez raison de
souligner que le Médiateur de l'énergie
a pour mission de s'adresser au ménage
et aux très petites entreprises et de
faire cette intermédiaire lorsqu'il y a
un conflit entre le fournisseur
d'énergie et le client en l'occurrence
dans le cas présent si votre entreprise
relève de la catégorie des très petites
entreprises ne dépassent pas une
certaine puissance il 3 un contrat au
tarif réglementé chez EDF s'il ne n'a
pas s'il n'est pas dans cette situation
un boulanger a souvent une puissance
importante pour faire fonctionner son
four à pain alors au titre de la charte
qui a été signé par l'ensemble des
fournisseurs d'énergie il a également
droit à un contrat un contrat qui payera
certes pour une partie au prix du marché
mais il bénéficiera de l'amortisseur
électrique que nous sommes en train de
mettre en place alors quel est son
interlocuteur c'est la creux la creux la
Commission de régulation de l'énergie
qui accompagne les entreprises pour
lesquelles les fournisseurs ne
joueraient pas le jeu vous savez que
tous les fournisseurs se sont engagés à
faire au moins une offre à des
entreprises à des collectivités locales
à des associations qui auraient du mal à
trouver un fournisseur un distributeur
d'énergie je me tiens à votre
disposition pour faire en sorte que le
cas isolé que vous ment soit très
rapidement réglé je vous remercie je
vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Nicolas
turquois pour le groupe démocrate
merci madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur et
des Outre-mer au nom du groupe démocrate
je tiens à vous exprimer nos plus
profonds remerciements qui concerne
l'otion Viking en autorisant l'accueil
de ce bateau dans le port de Toulon et
de ses 234 migrants vous avez tout
simplement fait œuvre d'humanité ce qui
devrait être pour tous ici le sens de
notre engagement
avoir entendre ou lire les déclarations
les plus odieuses de ces derniers jours
de cette séance je mesure la difficulté
à laquelle le gouvernement a été
confronté mais par votre décision la
France a honoré le mot fraternité qui
est inscrit sur le fronton de toutes les
mairies
si l'affaire de la chaîne Viking est
particulièrement symbolique elle n'est
que le reflet d'un problème beaucoup
plus large
avec la multiplication des conflits aux
portes de l'Europe en Afrique au
Moyen-Orient avec le drame du
réchauffement climatique avec un écart
considérable de richesse entre les deux
rives de la Méditerranée les flux de
migrants ne sont pas près de ce tarir
malgré les coûts de Menton de certains
le refus d'accueillir un bateau par
exemple nous dissuadera aucun migrant de
tenter sa chance avec son lot de drame
nous devons donc adopter une stratégie
d'une autre dimension sur le sujet de
l'immigration à la fois sur sa
régulation mais aussi sur son humanité
la réponse européenne n'est clairement
pas à la hauteur car elle laisse trop
seul les pays du sud de l'Europe
dans ce contexte monsieur le ministre
pourriez-vous nous expliquer de quelle
façon les migrants de le Sean Viking
vont-ils être accompagnés dans les
prochains jours et nous dire quelle
stratégie le gouvernement va porter sur
la question des drames migratoires la
Méditerranée ou la Manche ne peuvent
être plus ne peuvent plus être immenses
cimetière je vous remercie
je vous remercie mon cher collègue la
parole est à Monsieur Gérald Darmanin
ministre de l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
merci pour vos mots
évidemment en dehors de l'événement de
séance de novembre il y a deux manières
générales les flux de migration que nous
connaissons qui viennent vous l'avez dit
d'Afrique mais aussi d'Asie puisque une
partie des personnes qui cherchent le
refuge sur le territoire européen
viennent d'Afghanistan du Pakistan du
Bangladesh et d'ailleurs vous le savez
parfois même jusqu'au bout de l'Asie et
traverse deux continents une mer pour
arriver en Europe et nous devons en
effet d'abord de façon européenne
organisée la protection de nos
frontières et notre nécessaire de voir
d'humanité c'était tout le sens de la
présidence française de l'Union
européenne qui a porté une première
étape du pacte migratoire en échange une
solidarité plus forte avec les pays du
Sud la Grèce Chypre Malte d'Italie et
l'Espagne qui connaissait cette
migration c'était des fameuses
relocalisations ces pays s'engagés à une
certaine protection des frontières
notamment par des systèmes
un système comme Eurodac et
l'enregistrement de toute personne sur
le sol européen la France demande
d'ailleurs à l'Europe d'avoir une
demande unique d'asile pour éviter les
difficultés pour les personnes migrantes
qui arrivent sur le territoire européen
par ailleurs c'est flux importants de
migrants et qui vous avez raison peuvent
s'accélérer du fait des crises que vous
avez évoquées pour une partie d'entre
eux veulent passer en Grande-Bretagne et
c'est évidemment la Belgique et le nord
de la France qui subissent depuis plus
de 20 ans cette situation même si
aujourd'hui il y a 10 fois moins de
migrants à Calais qu'il y en a eu il y a
7 ans mais il reste une partie de
population qui veulent traverser la
Manche en effet et nous devons
absolument conclure avec la
Grande-Bretagne ce traité européen qui
nous permet enfin d'ouvrir une voie
légale en Grande-Bretagne aussi il
devrait dire aux Anglais de réformer
leur code du marché de travail pour un
mois attractif évidemment l'arrivée des
migrants chez eux merci monsieur
la parole est à Monsieur Johnny Hajar
pour le groupe socialiste
[Applaudissements]
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
madame la Première ministre la France a
adhéré à la banque de développement des
Caraïbes BDC en 1984 elle s'est retirée
de son capital 27 octobre 2000 pourtant
la BDC est le principal financeur de la
communauté des Caraïbes CARICOM de
l'Organisation des États de la Caraïbes
orientale ou océo dont la Martinique et
la Guadeloupe sont membres aussi le
retour de la France au capital de la BDC
est un acte essentiel de crédibilité de
la politique étrangère dans la région
Caraïbes mais aussi de financement des
actions de coopération régionale entre
les Collectivités Territoriales
Françaises d'Outre-Mer et les États de
la Caraïbe environnante ce retour
contribuerait à renforcer
particulièrement la coopération
économique et l'accès accru de nos
entreprises au marché lancé par la BDC
ainsi qu'au financement caribéen ce qui
constitue de fait une opportunité
d'ouverture économique et sociale pour
les Antilles Guyane sur un marché à peu
près de 40 millions d'habitants cela
permettra surtout à la Martinique à la
Guadeloupe au titre de la loi l'alchimie
de 2016 sous la coopération régionale
d'y adhéré également en qualité de
membres au même titre que les
territoires d'outre-mer britanniques de
l'osco c'est une condition fondamentale
de désenclavagement notamment économique
de notre territoire insulaires
d'intégration véritable dans nos bassins
régionaux voisins de développement
endogène encourageant la production
locale via la perspective d'un nouveau
modèle économique créateur entre autres
de richesse d'activités d'emplois et de
meilleures conditions de vie compte tenu
du contexte mondial difficile des défis
urgents relevés comme la CRT permanente
et insupportable de la vie les
changements climatiques il y a urgence
alors madame la Première ministre
conformément aux engagements pris par
l'État en mai 2015 confirmé en décembre
2016 pouvez-vous nous préciser la
programmation c'est à dire le calendrier
opérationnel retenu pour le retour de la
France au capital de la banque de
développement des Caraïbes je merci je
vous remercie la parole est à Monsieur
Gabriel Attal ministre délégué chargé
des comptes publics
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Johnny Hajar vous m'interrogez sur le
retour de la France au capital de la
banque de développement des Caraïbes qui
est effectivement une demande forte en
Martinique et à l'occasion de mon
déplacement en septembre dernier le
président les chimie m'avait fait part
de cette demande vous l'avez rappelé la
France avait adhéré à la banque de
développement des Caraïbes en 84 et s'en
est retiré en l'an 2000 à l'époque le
gouvernement avait considéré que ces
activités n'étaient pas assez dirigées
en faveur des pays les plus pauvres de
la région comme Haïti par exemple le
gouvernement de l'époque avait considéré
qu'elle n'avait pas assez favorisé
l'insertion et l'intégration régionale
des départements région d'outre-mer dans
leur environnement et enfin les retours
pour les entreprises françaises ne
semblaient pas être à la hauteur des
attentes pour autant depuis un certain
nombre de choses ont changé et justifie
que l'on se repose la question d'une
réadhésion à la banque de développement
des Cara pour les raisons que vous avez
évoquées j'ajouterai une autre raison
c'est que nous sommes à un moment où les
États-Unis recherchent une posture plus
active dans le bassin caribéen face à
une montée des intérêts de la Chine et
que notre pays doit évidemment se poser
la question des moyens d'être davantage
présent dans cette zone et ce territoire
à partir de là plusieurs questions se
posent pour trancher sur une nouvelle
adhésion ou non à la banque de
développement des Caraïbes d'abord
comment tenir compte du fait que la BDC
a comme pays d'opération des
juridictions non coopératives ou sur des
listes anti blanchiment deuxième chose
quel impact sur les ressources que nous
mettons au sein de la banque
inter-américaine de développement qui
est également actif dans la région enfin
il faut rappeler que la participation de
la France au capital de la BDC
entraînerait un coup budgétaire évalué
entre 30 et 90 millions d'euros c'est
potentiellement significatifs mais si
nous sommes capables de répondre aux
questions précédentes et de nous assurer
de l'intérêt réel pour notre pays et les
territoires que vous avez évoqués et que
vous représentez alors nous pourrons
nous engager dans cette voie je suis à
votre disposition pour continuer à
travailler sur ce sujet merci beaucoup
monsieur le ministre la parole est à
Madame Christine Le Nabour pour le
groupe Renaissance
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse au ministère du Travail du
plein emploi et de l'insertion la 26e
édition de la Semaine européenne pour
l'emploi des personnes handicapées à
débuter hier à quand le plein emploi
pour les personnes en situation de
handicap et la thématique retenue cette
année ce thème représente un défi mais
aussi la promesse que nous pouvons faire
aux personnes en situation de handicap
d'occuper la place qu'elle mérite dans
une société inclusive que nous appelons
de nos vœux depuis 2017 notre regard sur
le handicap change et c'est tant mieux
les mesures en faveur de l'emploi des
personnes en situation handicap voter et
mis en place ont permis de faire baisser
le taux de chômage de 6 points depuis
2017 passant de 17 à 13%. les retours à
l'emploi ont bondi de 25% sur les quatre
premiers mois de 2022 par rapport à 2021
le nombre d'apprentis a augmenté de plus
175 % entre 2019 et 2021 le duo D qui
aura lieu ce jeudi a été déployé sur le
territoire national en 2018 sous
l'impulsion de Soph plus elle cette
opération est le temps fort de cette
semaine et participe à changer le regard
sur le handicap en entreprise au cours
de cette journée une entreprise une
collectivité ou une association peut
accueillir une personne en situation de
handicap et former un duo avec un
professionnel volontaire l'édition 2021
a enregistré 17000 duos 32 % de plus
qu'en 2019 en 2021 le duodé a généré des
insertions dans 17% des duos pour cette
nouvelle édition 30 000 offres d'accueil
ont été déposées par les employeurs sur
la plateforme duodet.fr c'est une
journée qui permet aux employeurs de
découvrir les atouts et qualité
professionnelles des personnes
handicapées une journée qui permet aux
personnes handicapées de découvrir des
environnements de travail précisez
préciser un projet professionnel amorcé
un parcours d'insertion convaincre de
leur possibilité en termes d'intégration
de performance et d'autonomie nous
savons que l'emploi l'accès à l'emploi
des personnes handicapées reste encore
difficiles monsieur le ministre le
comité interministériel du handicap du 6
octobre dernier a lancé préparation de
la prochaine Conférence nationale du
handicap pouvez-vous nous rappeler les
différents gouvernement et le maintien
dans l'emploi des personnes handmercies
la parole est à Monsieur Olivier du soft
ministre du Travail du plein emploi et
de l'insertion merci dans la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la députés le nebabour vous avez raison
de rappeler que cette semaine se tient
la 26e semaine de l'emploi des personnes
en situation de handicap et cela nous
permet de souligner combien c'est une
priorité du gouvernement priorité avec
des actions d'ores et déjà mises en
oeuvre je pense à l'obligation nommer un
référent handicap dans les entreprises
de plus de 250 salariés dans les CFA je
pense aux plans de transformation des
esats je pense aussi au plan de
modernisation des entreprises adaptées
avec cette volonté d'aller toujours plus
d'inclusions les résultats commencent à
payer à la fois par la mise en œuvre des
mesures que je viens de citer mais aussi
par l'amélioration du contexte
économique et sur la dernière année le
chômage des personnes en situation de
handicap a baissé de 8%
et à l'échelle du de 5 ans le taux de
chômage des personnes handicapées est
passé de 19 à 13% mais cela reste du
plus de deux fois la moyenne des actifs
dans notre pays il faut donc aller plus
loin nous préparons la Conférence
nationale du handicap vous l'avez dit
avec Geneviève darrusèque nous préparons
une feuille de route pour l'emploi des
personnes en situation de handicap et
nous donnons des moyens pour y arriver
des moyens par le droit un décret va
être prochainement publié pour faciliter
les parcours du milieu protégé jusque
vers les entreprises dites ordinaires
avec la possibilité de cumuler les
mi-temps dans l'une ou l'autre des
structures nous nous mettons en oeuvre
de nouveaux moyens pour accompagner les
entreprises adaptées la loi de finances
pour 2023 prévoit ainsi près de 500
millions d'euros alors que c'était 460
millions d'euros en 2022 pour
accompagner les entreprises adaptées et
nous allons aussi renouveler des outils
dès à l'investissement à la
modernisation je pense notamment fataya
qui est le fond d'accompagnement des
transformations de les transformations
des entreprises adaptées que nous
reconduisons en 2023 pour financer ces
mêmes investissements la marche vers le
Pôle Emploi est qui est possible le
chômage a un nouveau baissé au troisième
trimestre en France nous sommes
désormais à 7,3% mais le plein d'emploi
pourrait être atteint doit être l'emploi
pour tous c'est un concerne tous les
actifs ça concerne évidemment les
personnes en situation de handicap en
partant d'un principe nul n'est-il
d'employable je vous remercie monsieur
le ministre Trump la parole est à
Monsieur Christophe Bex pour le groupe
la France insoumise
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre ce soir c'est la fin
c'est la fin de la remise à la pompe est
maintenant sérieusement vous faites quoi
votre politique du chèque de la remise
n'est pas la bonne la logique il
intervenir sur les marchés pour bloquer
les prix et conjointement augmenter les
serres les augmentations actuelles de
deux à trois pour cent dans un contexte
de 10% d'inflation signifie une baisse
générale des salaires
c'est indécent dans le monde d'en haut
où les records sont battus avec 150000
millions de profits pour le CAC 40 en
2021 vous nous répondez modération
salariale quand les grands patrons
bénéficient d'une augmentation de 52%
avec une rémunération moyenne de 6
millions c'est plus de 12 mig par jour
ce n'est pas nouveau déjà au siècle
dernier Raymond Barre en 1976 nous
disait serrez-vous la ceinture mais pour
quels résultats
j'appelle mes concitoyens a bien mesuré
ce moment
il y a pratiquement 4 ans jour pour jour
des femmes et des hommes se lever
revêtu d'un gilet jaune il et elle
occupé les ronds-points
manifester partout en France
ils ont été insultés stigmatisés et
victime d'une violente répression
leur faute avoir repris et chanté on est
là on est là même si Macron ne le veut
pas nous on est là pour l'honneur des
travailleurs et pour un monde meilleur
même si Macron ne le veut pas nous on
est là
oui oui pour un monde meilleur 8 sur la
possibilité de vivre
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Gabriel Attal ministre délégué
en charge des comptes publics
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Christophe Becks j'étais heureux de vous
entendre défendre l'aristourne carburant
votre groupe s'y est opposé à voter
contre vous avez voulu empêcher que
cette ristourne se mette en place ne
vous en déplaise cette majorité elle est
là et c'est cette majorité qui a permis
à l'Ariston de carburant de voir le jour
avec l'apport des républicains qui se
sont engagés aussi sur le sujet je ne
les oublie pas
monsieur le député depuis des mois vous
faites croire aux Français vous voulez
faire croire aux Français que vous
pourriez que nous pourrions bloquer les
prix de l'essence ça n'est pas vrai et
vous le savez très bien parce que vous
pouvez vous ne pouvez pas bloquer les
prix du pétrole la seule chose que vous
réussiriez à bloquer si vous étiez au
pouvoir c'est notre pays c'est notre
économie c'est nos raffinerie c'est
l'activité de celles et ceux qui
travaillent les seuls que vous défendez
dans notre pays c'est ce qui bloque et
ceux qui veulent entraver les autres
quand ils veulent travailler on l'a vu
encore ces dernières semaines et ces
derniers mois souffrez que nous
agissions pour limiter au maximum les
effets de l'inflation pour les Français
avec 110 milliards d'euros 110 milliards
d'euros en trois ans dépensé pour
limiter l'impact de l'inflation pour les
Français sur l'électricité sur le gaz
sur le fioul encore récemment sur les
pellets de bois dans un texte contre
lequel vous avez voté encore une fois
des mesures pour l'intérêt des Français
auxquels vous vous opposez c'est
systématique pour vous et ces mesures
elles sont financées en grande partie
par quoi Monsieur le Député par une
captation des super profits que nous
avons mis en place avec un mécanisme
européen 26 milliards d'euros et oui et
oui contrairement à ce que vous indiquez
nous allons chercher les rentes indues
pour les redistribuer aux Français c'est
la cohérence de cette majorité agir en
faveur de l'emploi agir pour limiter
l'impact de l'inflation sur le quotidien
des Français et ça je peux vous le dire
tant que nous on est là ça continuera
je vous remercie
[Musique]
la parole est à Madame Véronique louvagi
pour le groupe les républicains merci
madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur le Ministre de
l'économie et porte sur la méthode de
calcul du taux d'usure je ne compte plus
les messages de nos concitoyens déçus de
nos pouvoirs accomplir le projet d'une
vie qui est l'accession à la propriété
un dossier de prêt sur 5 en moyenne a
été refusé entre mars et mai 2022 la
situation a continué par ailleurs de se
dégrader avec un taux de refus d'un
dossier sur Torah voir 50% des dossiers
refusés pour les primo-accédants
effectivement un additionnant le taux
d'intérêt d'assurance des emprunteurs
très vite le taux d'usure est atteint et
la demande des ménages est facilement
rejetée les premières victimes sont par
ailleurs les familles modestes disposant
d'un faible apport personnel avec un
taux de crédit trop proche de l'usure
certes la situation n'est pas nouvelle
puisque les taux d'usure ont été
révisées en octobre à 3,05% pour les
crédits de 20 ans et plus et à 3,03%
pour les durées plus courtes mais les
établissements bancaires très vite
remonter leur taux or en période de
remontée sensible des taux de prêt un
pincement se produit entre les taux
bancaires pratiqués et le taux d'usure
calculé sur le trimestre précédent trop
en décalage de la réalité des taux réels
bref l'accès au crédit immobilier se
dégrade je ne conteste pas la notion
même de taux d'usure mais ça mécanique
ce retourne aujourd'hui contre ceux
qu'elle doit protéger des mécanismes
simples et efficaces existent afin de
remédier à cette situation je pense par
exemple à l'actualisation mensuelle du
taux d'usure ou à la révision de son
mode de calcul ma question est alors
simple comment comptez-vous intervenir
sur le taux d'usure pour permettre au
ménage d'accéder à la propriété je vous
remercie je vous remercie la parole est
à Madame Olivia Grégoire ministre
délégué chargé des petites et moyennes
entreprises du commerce de l'artisanat
et du tourisme
merci madame la présidente madame la
députée louvagi vous le soulignez à
raison et votre question est légitime
on a effectivement une remontée rapide
des taux d'intérêt qu'on a tous face à
nous et depuis quelques mois comme vous
l'avez expliqué ça a pu conduire en
réalité un retard un effet retard sur le
niveau des taux d'usure qui n'a pas
suivi c'est exactement le sens de votre
question les rendant trop contraignants
et par la même ça limite le la capacité
d'accès au crédit des particuliers mais
aussi des collectivités locales face à
ce constat que très clairement nous
partageons déjà le gouvernement et je
crois que vous le savez mais je le
répète dès la fin du mois d'août a mis
en place un cycle de travail très
opérationnel avec la Banque de France la
direction générale du Trésor les banques
les associations de consommateurs pour
faire un état des lieux complets du
sujet et surtout des impacts du taux du
jeu actuel
à l'issue de ce cycle de travail depuis
trois mois désormais un nouveau mode de
collègues des taux pratiqués par les
banques a été mise en oeuvre pour avoir
une vision plus fine plus détaillée des
taux moyen et c'est pourquoi d'ailleurs
le premier octobre dernier les
différents taux du jeu ont connu une
hausse significative justement pour
permettre de d'augmenter l'accès au
crédit des particuliers et des
collectivités qui rencontraient des
difficultés un exemple le taux d'usure
des crédits immobiliers à 20 ans
augmente de près de 0,5% en passant de
2,57 à
3,05%. dans des conditions que nous
connaissons de remontées du taux d'usure
le gouverneur de la Banque de France n'a
pas souhaité à cette heure proposer des
rejets à la formule de calcul du taux
d'usure néanmoins sachez que le
gouvernement surveille de très près le
sujet et sachez que nous resterons très
vigilants avec Bruno Le Maire qui est
retenu ce jour par le G20 à Bali vous le
savez pour s'assurer que le taux d'usure
permet de protéger
à la fois contre une charge de la dette
excessive mais aussi sur l'accès au
crédit on bougera en janvier 23 et on
vous invite à y travailler avec nous je
vous remercie madame louvaget
oui merci madame la Présidente merci
beaucoup madame la ministre pour votre
réponse j'attire votre attention sur
l'urgence des dispositions à intervenir
et j'ai bien entendu qu'il n'était pas
question de réviser les modes de calcul
du taux d'usure néanmoins je vous
propose de piste envisager
éventuellement une actualisation
mensuelle du taux d'usure et nos
patrimestrielle parce que les taux
d'intérêt varient chaque mois et un
deuxième point notamment concernant les
assurances des emprunteurs l'intégration
de l'assurance dans le taux annuel
effectif global n'a plus le même intérêt
qu'auparavant compte tenu des évolutions
réglementaires il pourrait y avoir une
réflexion sur le sujet merci beaucoup ma
chère collègue la parole est à Monsieur
Luc gesmin pour le groupe démocrate
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse au ministre de la santé et de
la prévention monsieur ministre au CHU
de Nantes comme dans de nombreuses
autres établissements hospitaliers de
France les services d'urgence
pédiatriques sont débordés l'origine
principale de cette saturation est liée
à la forte circulation depuis la fin du
mois d'octobre de la bronchiolite cette
infection respiratoire virale qui touche
surtout les enfants de moins de 2 ans
si cette épidémie est fréquente elle est
cette année particulièrement précoce et
virulente cette pathologie est dans la
majorité des cas bénigne mais cet
automne santé publique France pointe un
nombre de passage aux urgences et
d'hospitalisation pour bronchiolite très
élevé à Denise veau très supérieurs à
ceux observer au pic épidémie épidémique
depuis plus de 10 ans la situation
inquiète profondément les professionnels
de santé et les familles et ceux-ci a
juste titre le gouvernement a d'ailleurs
rapidement réagi avec le déclenchement
du plan Orsan mercredi dernier et avec
l'intensification des campagnes
d'information rappelant l'importance des
gestes barrières pour protéger les
enfants de cette infection ma question
s'articulera ainsi autour de deux
aspects le préventif et le curatif
monsieur le ministre alors que désormais
votre ministère comprend officiellement
la prévention dans son périmètre n'y
a-t-il pas un changement de méthode à
fournir dans l'anticipation de la
survenance des épidémies saisonnières en
termes d'éducation et d'informations
je vous remercie mon cher collègue la
parole est à Monsieur François brode
ministre de la santé et de la prévention
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
jasmard je profite de votre question
tout d'abord pour saluer la mobilisation
totale de nos ARS des professionnels de
santé de la ville et de l'hôpital pour
fête faire face à cette épidémie vous
l'avez dit particulièrement inhabituelle
par sa précocité par son intensité
concernant les mesures de prévention
vous avez raison il est temps que nous
changeions notre logiciel sur la
prévention il est temps de transformer
notre pays qui est concentré autour du
soin vers un pays qui s'intéresse et qui
se concentre à la prévention c'est tout
l'enjeu du déploiement de la politique
de prévention voulue par ce gouvernement
et qui s'articule avec ce ministère vous
l'avez dit devenu ministère de la santé
et de la prévention
vous allez rappeler en ce qui concerne
cette épidémie l'importance des gestes
barrières je veux le rappeler encore ici
que ce soit la covid la bronchiolite la
grippe qui arrive ces gestes sont tous
des virus respiratoires les gestes
barrières le lavage de mains le port du
masque quand on est malade dans les
lieux où il y a beaucoup de monde sont
indispensables indispensables aussi la
vaccination je ne reviens pas sur la
grippe el covid mais la vaccination en
ce qui concerne la bronchiolite arrive
un peu tard cette année elle vient
d'être validée au niveau européen elle
sera possible l'année prochaine pour la
saison de l'année prochaine
concernant cette gestion de crise et
vous avez parlé du déclenchement du plan
hors-sant nos Ars en sont le pivot ce
plan s'articule en quatre parties
principales d'abord piloter les
capacités hospitalières nous avons eu
plus de 2500 hospitalisations depuis le
début de cette crise les services de
réanimation sont suivis de très près en
particulier leur capacité avec des
différences vous le savez entre les
régions ça permet de mobiliser tous les
acteurs qui sont sur le terrain les
médecins généralistes les pédiatres les
masseurs kinésithérapeutes
l'hospitalisation à domicile vous l'avez
rappelé la majorité des cas ne se traite
pas à l'hôpital l'accompagnement des
familles est assuré lorsque les enfants
sont transférés et puis le suivi de
l'épidémie est fait de très près par les
directions du ministère je vous remercie
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre la
parole est à Madame Sophie blanc pour le
coup rassemblement national
je vous remercie madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse au ministre des
Transports voilà maintenant 30 ans que
les majorités politiques successives
envisage la construction de la portion
de la ligne à grande vitesse entre
Montpellier et Perpignan malgré
l'utilité de ce projet structurant pour
le désenclavement économique de l'Aude
et des Pyrénées-Orientales on assiste
encore aujourd'hui à de nombreuses
tergiversations quand on financement de
ce projet malgré les annonces faites par
l'ancien premier ministre Jean Castex
alors en période électorale dans le
cadre de la loi de finances de 2022 le
Parlement a adopté un amendement
présenté par l'ancien gouvernement qui
vise à financer en partie la
construction de la LGV entre Bordeaux et
Toulouse cet amendement instaure une
taxe spéciale d'équipement qui serait
levée par les collectivités
territoriales actant par la même le
désengagement de l'État sur des
équipements d'utilités nationales et
internationales qui sont pourtant de sa
compétence de fait la perspective d'une
mise en place dans une taxe pour la
ligne nouvelle Montpellier Perpignan
inquiète les collectivités territoriales
et les habitants des départements
concernés en outre l'état et la SNCF se
désengagent de plus en plus du
financement ferroviaire et c'est
toujours au collectivités territoriales
de compenser ce manquement nous
soutenons l'idée que l'État devrait
pourtant remplir son rôle historique de
financeur et gestionnaire des LGV la
participation l'Union Européenne a une
hauteur de seulement 20% du protocole de
financement est insuffisante aussi mes
interrogations et celles de toute une
région sont claires monsieur le ministre
l'état va-t-il laisser les collectivités
territoriales seules face aux bouclage
financier de ce projet alors que les
départements de l'Aude et des
Pyrénées-Orientales marqués par des taux
de chômage et de pauvreté records
attendent avec impatience cet équipement
qui assurerait leur désenclavement et
participerait à leur essor économique je
vous remercie je vous remercie la parole
est Clément Beaune ministre délégué
chargé des transports madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés madame la députée Sophie blanc
la réponse est claire non l'État ne
laissera pas tomber les collectivités et
oui l'État est au rendez-vous de Céline
structurantes dont la ligne entre
Montpellier et Perpignan vous l'avez
replacé dans un contexte plus général
qui est important de rappeler en
quelques mots depuis un vote du
Parlement et la loi d'orientation des
mobilités nous avons décidé en effet
pour préserver les petites lignes et les
réseaux ferroviaires qui sont je crois
chers à toutes et tous ici d'avoir pour
les lignes à grande vitesse nouvelle des
modes de financement innovants ils sont
consistent à créer des sociétés de
projets qui sont un partenariat entre
l'État les collectivités locales l'état
confidence et des sociétés de projets
ont désormais été créés pour les trois
lignes que vous avez mentionnées la
ligne entre Montpellier et Perpignan la
ligne GPSO dans le Sud-Ouest et la ligne
entre Marseille et Nice dans la région
provençale peut-côte d'Azur les sociétés
sont créées les financements de l'État
seront au rendez-vous le conseil de
rotation de l'infrastructures auquel
vous participez aura l'occasion de
préciser les trajectoires budgétaires et
pour aider les collectivités à financer
leur part c'est ressources locales sont
un outil mise à disposition ce débat
continuera d'ailleurs des le débat
budgétaire au Sénat dans quelques jours
des amendements sont en préparation
concertés avec les élus locaux y compris
pour Montpellier Perpignan pour que ces
ressources soient voulues choisis
accepter localement car il me paraît
juste que le monde économique notamment
qui bénéficiera en premier de ces
aménagements et de ses trajectoires
nouvelles puisqu'tr contribuer de
manière concertée avec les collectivités
locales en complément du financement de
l'État sur le dernier point le
financement l'Union européenne je suis
heureux je le dis avec un petit sourire
que votre groupe salue l'engagement de
l'Union européenne et demande plus de
financement européen c'est très
important que nous saluons l'engagement
de l'Union européenne dans nos grands
projets d'infrastructures et nous nous
battons ravis que vous soyez en soutien
de cette démarche pour obtenir le
maximum de financement de l'Europe sur
circling et sur plusieurs autres
merci Monsieur le Ministre
madame blanc
l'Union européenne finance seulement à
20% elle pourrait financer davantage
avec notre argent je vous rappelle il
faut ma chère collègue
la parole est à Madame Soumia bourreau à
pour le groupe GDR
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse aux ministres de l'Intérieur
et des Outre-mer nous en convenons
toutes et toutes les droits des femmes
doivent être assurés partout dans le
monde partout où elle se trouve en
Afghanistan les semaines passent et la
situation s'aggrave pour les femmes
interdit d'école de travail de
déplacement sans l'accompagnement d'un
homme elles sont désormais exclues de
nombreux lieux publics et prier de
rester enfermés chez elle hier les
talibans ont annoncé qu'ils appliqueront
désormais strictement la loi islamique
signant ainsi le retour des exécutions
flagellation amputation et lapidation en
public c'est pourquoi de nombreuses
athlètes de haut niveau tentent chaque
jour de fuir l'Afghanistan pour échapper
à la répression des talibans
avec Marie-Georges Buffet nous avons
alerté à de nombreuses reprises sur le
sort des sept joueuses de l'équipe
nationale afghane de handball réfugiés
depuis de nombreux mois à Islamabad ou
Pakistan nous avons alerté le ministère
des Affaires étrangères Matignon
l'Élysée et votre ministère de plusieurs
semaines toutes les conditions sont
remplies pour que leur accueil soit
pleinement assuré en France grâce à
l'anglacement de la Fédération Française
de Handball et de son président ainsi de
nombreux élus aussi des nombreux élus
locaux sont prêts à pérenniser leur
accueil toutes les tous les
interlocuteurs que nous avons rencontrés
nous ont dit qu'ils allaient agir
rapidement pour qu'elles obtiennent un
visa pourtant c'est cette jeune femme
non à notre connaissance toujours pas
été contacté par l'ambassade de France à
Islamabad et vivent dans des conditions
indignes et non sécuritaires ma question
est la suivante pouvez-vous monsieur le
ministre me préciser quand des visas
leur seront contribuer je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
je vous remercie ma chère collègues la
parole est à Monsieur Gérald Darmanin
ministre de l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
madame la Présidente
en accord avec la ministre des Affaires
étrangères sous l'autorité du Président
de la République et même après ministre
nous accorderons des titres de séjour
pour ces personnes et si elle dépose une
demande d'asile en France sachant que
c'est l'OFPRA qui étudie ces demandes
d'asile par nature si on peut avoir une
décision politique dans ce domaine nous
souhaitons qu'elle puisse trouver
l'asile sur le territoire national les
services de Madame étrangère qui est
absente aujourd'hui vous aurez précisé
que nous terminons un certain nombre de
discussions notamment autour de la
sécurité vous savez que par ailleurs à
estebab les choses peuvent être
complexes également et dès que cela sera
possible dans les meilleurs moments et
dans les façons les plus sécurisées pour
elle ne pourrons non seulement délivrer
le titre de séjour et contribuer à leur
appartement sur le territoire de la
République
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
madame brouha merci merci monsieur le
ministre pour votre réponse il y a
urgence ces femmes sont en danger et il
faut faire vraiment très vite et puis ça
a du sens dans le dans le cadre de des
Jeux Olympiques pour défendre la
pratique sportive des femmes ici et
ailleurs merci ma chère collègue
la parole est à Monsieur Alexis Corbière
pour le groupe la France insoumise
madame la Première ministre dimanche
débutera la 22e Coupe du monde de
football au Qatar pays sans réel
tradition footballistique par contre
l'attribution à cette monarchie
pétrolière obtenue en 2010 étant
entachée par de réels soupçons de
corruption dans laquelle des personnages
politiques français majeurs seraient
intervenu et aux profonde ramifications
géopolitique 6500 c'est le nombre
d'ouvriers étrangers qui seraient décédé
après avoir travaillé sur les chantiers
sans eau potable 12 heures par jour 7
jours sur
760 c'est le nombre de vols quotidiens
toutes les 10 minutes entre Doha et des
capitales des pays voisins où seront
logés les supporters à cela s'ajoute la
climatisation dans des stades à ciel
ouvert situé au milieu du désert et une
empreinte carbone totale qui devrait
être comprise entre 6 et 7 millions de
tonnes de CO2 0 c'est le nombre de
partis politiques de syndicats ou encore
de manifestations autorisées dans cette
monarchie réactionnaire que pourtant des
policiers français vont aider dans
lequel on ne reconnaît pas l'égalité la
femme et où l'homosexualité est
interdite et puni par la loi c'est
pourquoi Amnesty International human
rightwatch demande à la FIFA qui va
percevoir 6 milliards de dollars de
recettes de créer un fond
d'indemnisation aux travailleurs
immigrés aux familles des victimes sans
qui cette compétition n'aurait pu se
dérouler comme 120 députés de tout bord
politique je soutiens complètement cette
exigence et regrette vivement que la
FIFA a refuse quelle est la position de
votre gouvernement votre Ministre des
Sports et le président de la République
ont déclaré qu'il ne se rendrait pas au
Qatar sauf si l'équipe de France atteint
l'écart et les demi-finales où est la
cohérence la protestation contre l'oubli
l'ignorance et le mépris des droits de
l'homme
ne varie pas en fonction du parcours
sportif d'une équipe c'est pourquoi nous
vous disons une chose simple et nous
vous la demandons boycott diplomatique
de cette Coupe du Monde de la honte
c'est là qu'elle courage et la dignité
l'argent du Qatar ne doit jamais pouvoir
acheter le silence de la France je vous
remercie je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame Amélie ou da
Castéra ministre des Sports et des Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques
madame la Présidente Mesdames Messieurs
les Députés monsieur le député corbial
vous le savez la décision de la FIFA
d'attribuer la Coupe du Monde 2022 au
Qatar est prise il y a 12 ans quand
Kylian Mbappe avait lui-même 12 ans le
mondial de foot démarre en effet
dimanche et nos joueurs avec qui j'étais
hier soir se prépare de longues dates
pour la réussir la France pas plus
d'ailleurs qu'aucun de ses partenaires
ne boycotra cette Coupe du Monde et oui
j'irai soutenir l'équipe de France elle
avance dans la compétition c'est mon
rôle de ministre des Sports 10.000
français ont également prévu de se
rendre au Qatar pour encourager notre
sélection nationale et seront protégés
par les gendarmes et les policiers
français notamment Messieurs les Députés
nous croyons à la force de l'action
diplomatique et la France
œuvre de manière constante pour que tant
sur les droits humains que sur le
terrain écologique le Qatar non
seulement consolide ses progrès reconnu
par Amnesty et human right Swatch mais
les accélères sur la question en
particulier des travailleurs migrants
vous avez raison de pointer le indiqué
qu'un fonds d'indemnisation existait
déjà et qu'il était ouvert à le
mobiliser pour ma part comme je m'y
étais engagée y compris dans nos
échanges monsieur le député j'ai invité
la FIFA à mettre en place une
contribution financière au titre de
l'héritage de la compétition et à
consacrer cette contribution à
l'indemnisation des familles et des
travailleurs vous l'avez vu aussi la
lettre des Bleus ce midi par laquelle il
rappelle leur attachement au respect des
droits humains et s'engage à soutenir
les ONG qui œuvrent pour leur protection
grâce à leur fonds de dotation
génération 98 la Fédération Française de
Football elle-même en suivi de mes
demandes d'exemplarité a pris des
mesures pour s'assurer du respect des
conditions de travail et des droits
sociaux sur le camp de base de l'équipe
de France vous le voyez monsieur le
député
chacun prend sa part à cette nécessaire
effort collectif nos bleus partent
demain souhaitons leur bonne chance je
vous remercie madame la ministre
monsieur Corbière
[Applaudissements]
l'équipe de France n'a pas besoin
d'Emmanuel peucron pour gagner mais les
droits d'hommes auront toujours besoin
de la France pour gagner aussi je vous
remercie
[Musique]
la parole est à Madame félicit Gérard
pour le groupe horizon
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre du
Travail du plein emploi et de
l'insertion monsieur le ministre
l'emploi des seniors dans notre pays est
un enjeu majeur à ce sujet les chiffres
parlent d'eux-mêmes si les seniors sont
relativement moins concernés en nombre
par le chômage ils y restent en moyenne
deux fois et demi plus longtemps que les
autres demandeurs d'emploi ce problème
ce problème se ressent sur le terrain
comme nombre de mes collègues j'ai eu
l'occasion de rencontrer sur mon
territoire des missions locales et des
entreprises de réinsertion qui partagent
le même constat l'emploi des seniors est
une préoccupation importante pour les
demandeurs d'emploi concernés pour les
organismes de réinsertion et pour les
employeurs eux-mêmes en effet l'emploi
des seniors est perçu par cette scène de
nos entreprises comme un investissement
moins rentable que l'emploi d'un salarié
en début ou en milieu de carrière
cela s'explique par le coup salarial par
le fait que la dernière entreprise du
salarié est chargé d'assumer les
maladies professionnelles mais également
par la peur d'investir du temps de
formation et d'intégration d'un salarié
en fin de carrière par ailleurs nous
faisons face nous faisons face de la
part des seniors à un important
phénomène d'autocensure vis-à-vis de
l'emploi certains d'entre eux se
considèrent une employables ne pensent
pas avoir les compétences adaptées pour
travailler dans un secteur différent de
leur ancien poste ou encore s'inquiète
de leur légitimité à suivre des
formations professionnelles parfois
nécessaires au retour à l'emploi
monsieur le ministre l'emploi des
seniors est essentiel pour notre pays et
précieux pour nos entreprises par les
compétences et l'expérience qu'ils
apportent
face à ces difficultés pourriez-vous
nous indiquer quel dispositif peuvent
être mis en place afin de favoriser la
formation chez les seniors accompagner
leur fin de carrière et inciter les
entreprises à les embaucher par ailleurs
pourriez-vous nous préciser dans quelle
mesure les concertations que vous menez
en ce moment sur la réforme des
retraites peuvent apporter des réponses
structurelles sur le sujet je vous
remercie je vous remercie la parole est
à Monsieur Olivier du soft ministre du
Travail du plein emploi et de
l'insertion merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la députée Félicie Gérard vous avez
raison ce que vous faites le constat que
l'emploi des seigneurs dans notre pays
est moins développé que dans tous les
autres pays de l'Union Européenne le
taux de chômage le taux d'emploi pardon
des seniors de plus de 50 ans s'élève à
56% alors que le taux d'emploi de toute
la population le taux moyen est à 68%
c'est un taux qui est élevé puisque nous
avons rejoint le taux que nous
connaissions en 1972 cette marge vers
plein d'emploi cette part plus
importante de la population à être en
emploi ne doit pas laisser les seniors
sur le côté du chemin et nous devons
tout mettre en oeuvre pour permettre
aussi le retour et le maintien de
l'emploi de ceux qui ont plus de 50 plus
de 55 ou plus de 60 ans pour cela nous
ouvrons des constatations multiples et
cette question de l'emploi des seniors
et finalement à la confluence de
nombreux dossiers que j'ai apporté à la
fois la réforme des retraites celle de
la modulation des règles d'indemnisation
en matière d'assurance chômage mais en
réalité tout ce qui concours aux pleins
d'emploi et à l'emploi de tous à
l'échelle de l'ensemble de notre pays
nous travaillons actuellement sur quatre
pistes la première piste concerne la
formation nous devons investir dans la
formation des seniors leur expérience
est riche mais elle doit aussi être
parfois accompagnée d'une montée en
puissance d'une montée en qualification
sur certaines nouvelles technologies
mais aussi pour appréhender une façon de
terminer sa carrière sur d'autres
métiers que ceux exercés précédemment et
c'est aussi une des conditions de
maintien dans l'emploi nous devons
travailler en matière de prévention
l'usure professionnelle parce que bien
souvent la sortie de l'emploi des plus
âgés des actifs de notre pays
s'expliquent par des questions liées à
des invalidités à des in études ou à des
troubles musculo-squelettiques qui sont
la caractéristique de l'usure
professionnelle et la prévention
permettra aussi le maintien dans
l'emploi nous avons une troisième piste
qui est bercé dans ses concertations
consistant à mettre en place des outils
de gestion de l'emploi des seniors
certaines organisations syndicales ont
fait la proposition de créer un index
sur le modèle de ce qui a été fait en
matière d'égalité professionnelle entre
les femmes et les hommes je ne sais si
l'index et la solution la plus idoine
mais je sais de manière certaine que
nous devons avoir cet outil de gestion
et de transparence sur la question de
l'emploi des seniors et enfin nous avons
un chantier majeur
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre la
parole est à madame Béatrice Descamps
pour le groupe yote merci madame la
Présidente ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'éducation
nationale et de la jeunesse monsieur le
ministre l'école est un moment
fondetteur pour notre jeunesse c'est ce
lieu et ce temps où elle doit acquérir
des compétences s'enrichir s'épanouir se
construire apprendre à vivre ensemble
c'est aussi un endroit où notre Genèse
doit être protégé mais nous savons tous
à quel point ce moment peut devenir
douloureux pour certains élèves victimes
de harcèlement et la journée nationale
contre le harcèlement à l'école jeudi
dernier a montré combien chacun voulait
se mobiliser je l'ai constaté moi-même
au collège de Quiévrechain dans ma
circonscription
ce moment peut devenir douloureux aussi
pour certains élèves en perte de
confiance souffrant psychologiquement et
moralement ou pour d'autres atteints de
certaines pathologies et qui ont besoin
de se sentir rassurés dans leur
établissement ainsi que dans les centres
d'examens aujourd'hui ces écoles
collègues lycées mais tout en œuvre j'en
suis convaincu avec les moyens que sont
les leurs pour ce que chaque élève soit
accueilli le mieux possible et puisse
réussir dans la voie qui sera la
meilleure pour lui et je salue ici le
travail des personnels de l'Éducation
nationale mais monsieur le ministre nous
nous devons absolument de réagir face au
manque notoire et très inquiétant de
psychologues scolaire d'infirmiers de
médecins scolaire certains postent étant
d'ailleurs ouvert et non pourvu nous le
savons aussi Monsieur le Ministre ma
question sera double quelle réponse
pouvez-vous apporter rapidement pour
pallier un minima à ce manque de
professionnel dans nos écoles y a-t-il
un travail de fond prévu sur ce sujet
les parlementaires que nous sommes
pourront-ils y être associés je vous
remercie
je vous remercie ma chère collègues la
parole est à Monsieur papenzahi ministre
de l'éducation nationale et de la
jeunesse merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la député Béatrice Descamps vous l'avez
souligné le problème est moins en
matière de santé scolaire et surtout de
médecine scolaire un problème de poste
que d'attractivité du métier si l'on
considère l'ensemble du pays 30% des
postes de médecins scolaires sont
aujourd'hui vacants mais nous avons de
grandes difficultés pour trouver les
personnels nous pourrions doubler le
nombre de postes que cela ne changerait
rien si l'on prend le cas d'un
département rural comme celui des Vosges
il y a huit postes de médecine scolaire
il est 8 postes sont vacants nous avons
recours à deux postes à deux médecins
vacataires dans ce département pourtant
depuis 2017 il y a eu un effort de
revalorisation des professions de santé
scolaire avec des passages facilités à
la première classe et alors classe avec
le passage au troisième grade pour les
médecins scolaires avec des primes en
éducation prioritaire la situation est
un peu meilleure du côté des infirmiers
et des psychologues scolaires avec une
attractivité des concours qui est
meilleur mais il n'en demeure pas moins
que d'une manière générale la question
de la santé scolaire et posée au-delà
des nécessaires mesures statutaires et
financières que nous avons prises
l'enjeu c'est bien celui de refonder la
médecine scolaire pour cela et à la
demande du Parlement dans le cadre de la
loi 3DS nous préparons avec le ministre
de la santé et de la prévention un
rapport sur l'avenir de la médecine
scolaire avec trois inspections
générales ce rapport devrait être
terminé en début d'année 2023 et il
pourra donner lieu à ce moment là à un
débat parlementaire avec l'ensemble des
députés et je salue naturellement votre
engagement sur ce sujet je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre la parole est à
Madame Joël Melin pour le groupe
rassemblement national
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à monsieur Clément bonne
ministre des Transports monsieur le
ministre en 2014 l'Union européenne a
adopté une directive de contrôle des
véhicules motorisés de cylindrée
supérieure à 125 cm3 l'objectif c'était
de diviser par deux en disant le nombre
de morts sur les routes or en France le
pourcentage de mort par défaillance
technique de cette catégorie n'est déjà
que de 0,3% des accidents un des moyens
envisagés étaient le contrôle technique
mais une exemption était prévue si les
États membres avaient pu mettre en place
des mesures de sécurité alternative au
regard de statistiques pertinentes
malheureusement l'état français ne l'a
fait que partiellement suppression de
tous les points noirs double glissières
de sécurité amélioration de l'état de
toutes les routes secondaires se font
encore attendre retard préjudiciable
comme le souligne les associations des 2
millions de motards français en
particulier la Fédération des bikers de
France dans les faits les motos
circulant en moyenne 6000 km par an par
similitudes avec les voitures ne devrait
être contrôlé que tous les 5 ans et non
tous les deux ans la proposition des
motards serait un contrôle obligatoire
moins contraignant lors de la session
des motos en moyenne tous les deux à
trois ans de plus c'est contrôle
nécessitant des investissements
techniques et humains pour des centres
agréés serait difficile à rentabiliser
reportant obligatoirement les coûts sur
les contrôles techniques des voitures il
serait donc souhaitable de solliciter en
priorité tous les artisans français
spécialisés déjà équipés formés et agréé
pour ces modifications d'équipements
moteurs en moteur électrique ou esthanol
l'utilisation de pièces européennes
estampillées plutôt que extraort
européenne dont les véhicules neufs sont
dépendants de l'éloignement et des
terres rares alors ma question est
simple monsieur le ministre après la
décision du Conseil d'État mettre en
difficulté notamment financière 2
millions de motards par un contrôle
contraignant où allez-vous transposer
les directives
alternatives merci beaucoup ma chère
collègue la réponse
la parole est à monsieur Clément bonne
ministre délégué des transports merci
madame la présidente Madame et Messieurs
les Députés madame la députés Joëlle
Meslin vous rappelez historique d'un
dossier important je voudrais apporter
quelques précisions car vous l'avez dit
pour 2 millions de moteurs en
particulier c'est une forte
préoccupation partagée par le
gouvernement il y a une directive qui
date de 2014 qui prévoit deux options
soit la mise en place d'un contrôle
technique la vérité oblige à dire que
c'est l'option qui ont suivi l'immense
majorité des pays européens parfois
d'ailleurs de longue date et une option
qui consiste à mettre en place des
mesures alternatives je préciser parce
qu'on ne peut pas laisser croire les
choses qui seraient inexactes au moteur
qui attendent des réponses précises il
n'est pas vrai que les efforts légitimes
et nécessaires par ailleurs en matière
de sécurité routière la limitation des
glissières dangereuses un certain nombre
d'aménagements routiers consiste à
remplir ces obligations de mesure
alternatives les mesures alternatives
telles qu'elles sont prévues par la
directive ce sont des mesures qui
portent sur les véhicules eux-mêmes et
donc c'est de cela qu'on parle c'est la
voix qui a été suivie en par mes
prédécesseurs avec les fédérations de
motards et plusieurs fois des mesures
alternatives ont été décidées le
gouvernement avait décidé de poursuivre
dans cette voie il y a eu des recours
nous sommes dans un état de droit le
Conseil d'État livraison interprétation
sans ambiguïté de la directive par sa
décision du 31 octobre dernier et
demande de mettre en place un contrôle
technique le gouvernement doit le
respecter j'ai néanmoins décidé par ta
journée préoccupations vous avez
relayées qui sont là aussi légitimes
notamment sur la question de pouvoir
d'achat notamment sur les questions de
sécurité qui sont partagées par tous les
motards j'ai engagé une concertation
avec l'ensemble des partis fédérations
de motards que j'ai reçu à deux reprises
dès cet été la semaine dernière les
associations requérantz et ce matin
encore les centres techniques agréés qui
seraient en charge de ces modalités de
contrôle parce que je partage l'idée que
l'on doit faire les choses de la manière
évidemment conforme aux droits et aux
décisions du Conseil d'État mais en
préservant le pouvoir d'achat en prenant
des mesures qui sont proportionnées et
c'est à l'issue de circoncertation que
le gouvernement j'aurai l'occasion de
revenir les présentera avant la fin de
l'année en préservant le pouvoir d'achat
et la sécurité au mieux je vous remercie
monsieur
merci merci madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse à Madame la première
minute le président de la République
reconnaissait le 11 février dernier au
sommet mondial de l'océan que la pêche
illicite est un fléau il s'affiche
aujourd'hui sur Twitter pour tenter de
vendre non sans quelques contre-vérités
une supposée politique écologiste que
votre gouvernement a bien du mal à
incarner et pour cause en même temps en
même temps la France contourne depuis
des années la réglementation européenne
sur la pêche elle permet à ses tonnier
des pesets globales et non espèces par
espèces rendant illusoire le respect des
quotas la Commission européenne a ouvert
une procédure d'infraction contre la
France en juin 2021
en ce moment même des négociations ont
lieu à Bruxelles pour faire changer la
réglementation la France appui cette
révision pour que les marges d'erreur
aujourd'hui à 10% passent à 25% pour la
pêche au thon et pour la pesée globale
et pour que la pesée globale devienne la
norme impossible dans ces conditions de
respecter les quotas qui par définition
se font espèce par espèce c'est
irresponsable
nous apprenons par ailleurs et je
remercie ici l'OMG Blum ainsi que les
journalistes de France Info nous
apprenons qu'une haute fonctionnaire de
la Direction Générale des Affaires
maritimes a été recrutée par le
principal lobby européen de la pêche
europêche cette haute fonctionnaire
connaît parfaitement les rouages
l'agenda les dossiers elle a eu à les
traiter directement
elle passe pourtant dans le privé sans
respect de du délai légal de trois ans
et donc avec l'autorisation de la
Commission de déontologie du ministère
des armées tout cela est effarant madame
la Première ministre ce pantouflage au
moment de la renégociation du règlement
européen du contrôle des pêches
répond-il à une volonté politique de la
France en avez-vous eu connaissance
quant allez-vous cesser d'affaiblir les
mécanismes de protection de la
biodiversité et de la ressource
halieutique je vous remercie
la parole est un monsieur
Hervé Berville secrétaire d'État chargé
de la mer
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député Jérémy Yordanov alors
vous évoquez plusieurs sujets le premier
d'abord celui de la volonté du
gouvernement de défendre à la fois la
préservation des océans et en même temps
de défendre nos pêcheurs parce que pour
l'enjeu de la souveraineté alimentaire
nous avons besoin d'avoir des pêcheurs
et c'est pour ça qu'on a eu une volonté
affichée très forte de soutenir
notamment nos pêcheurs face à
l'augmentation du prix du carburant avec
les aides carburant qui s'élèvent à plus
de 40 millions d'euros c'est pour
soutenir nos petits pêcheurs c'est pour
soutenir et bien la souveraineté
alimentaire de notre pays ensuite vous
évoquez un sujet très précis celui au
fond en effet vous l'avez évoqué de la
marge de tolérance contrairement à ce
que vous avez dit la France nous
soutient absolument pas une marge de
tolérance à 25% en effet la France comme
d'autres pays a été mis en demeure par
la commission respect de respecter un
centre de choses ça arrive dans d'autres
domaines nous le faisons nous sommes en
train de travailler avec tous les
acteurs pour le faire ce que nous
portons avec le Parlement européen avec
d'autres pays membres de l'Union
européenne c'est au fond d'avoir dans
ces contrôles une marge de tolérance de
10% pourquoi parce que quand vous pêchez
du thon et bien vous devez le congeler
directement en raison des fortes
chaleurs et donc nous demandons d'avoir
au fond du bon sens du pragmatique et de
mettre en place ces 10% qui vont de pair
avec la mise en place obligatoire de
caméra sur les navires et nous avons là
la politique dans l'espace maritime
mondial la plus stricte la plus stricte
de préservation des océans de la
préservation d'un ressource halieutiques
et puis vous évoquez le sujet d'une
administrative des affaires maritimes
qu'il a est allé travailler non pas pour
un lobby comme vous le dites mais pour
une association qui emploie des
entreprises françaises et démarrer un
Français toutes les procédures ont été
respectées nous avons même saisi la
commission déontologie alors que ce
n'était pas obligatoire et la Commission
d'othologie a indiqué qu'il n'y avait
pas d'incompétilité donc vous voyez nous
mon offrons une travail sur l'exigence
sur la probité et en même temps sur la
préservation des ressources haliotiques
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Madame Pascal Boyer pour
le groupe Renaissance
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires à la cop27 qui se
déroule depuis le 6 novembre à Sharm el
shake le président de la République a
renouvelé l'engagement de la France pour
lutter contre le changement climatique
afin de tenir les objectifs de l'accord
de Paris pour regagner la confiance la
justice climatique doit être établie les
engagements des pays riches vis-à-vis
des pays les plus vulnérables doivent
être tenus la solidarité est
indispensable pour améliorer la
résilience des pays les plus démunis
confronté au choc et strex climatique
cependant la bataille pour le climat est
indissociable de la bataille pour la
biodiversité le rapport de l'ipves
publié en 2022 souligne le lien étroit
existant entre économie survie des
populations et maintient des écosystèmes
or de nombreuses espèces sont
aujourd'hui et surexploitées beaucoup
d'écosystèmes sont menacés en tant que
président de l'AS nationale des élus de
la montagne je relai les inquiétudes des
élus mais aussi des femmes et des hommes
qui vivent dans ces écrins de nature
l'Organisation des Nations Unies a
alerté sur le fait qu'un tiers
classés au patrimoine mondial de
l'UNESCO allait disparaître d'ici 2050
quel que soit le scénario climatique
seul une baisse des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre
préservera de la fonte les deux tiers
des glaciers restants selon le GIEC la
fonte des glaces et des neiges fait
partie des 10 menaces majeures causées
par le réchauffement climatique dans ce
contexte comment le gouvernement
compte-t-il concilier nos ambitions en
matière de climat avec nos ambitions en
matière de biodiversité quel est
l'articulation envisagée entre la cop27
et la COP15 qui se déroulera en décembre
prochain à Montréal pouvez-vous
également nous présenter monsieur le
ministre les dispositifs
d'accompagnement financiers que la
France a prévu à destination des pays
les plus vulnérables afin de les aider
la surface au défi climatique et
écologique je vous remercie je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur
Christophe Béchu ministre de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la députée
vous avez raison de lier ces deux coqs
et de bien préciser que derrière la
cop27 en jeep il y aura la COP15 dans
quelques semaines
à Montréal la journée d'aujourd'hui en
Égypte et d'ailleurs consacrée à la
biodiversité dans le cadre de la cop27
pour essayer de rehausser le niveau
d'ambition de ce que pourrait être les
conclusions de la COP15 le président de
la République dans le discours qu'il a
tenu en Égypte a bien dit que la
biodiversité ne devait pas être l'angle
mort d'une politique centrée sur la
baisse des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre parce que les deux sujets sont
liés nos écosystèmes nos espèces elles
sont menacées par le réchauffement
climatique et dans le même temps nos
écosystèmes participent à la lutte
contre ce dérèglement climatiques notre
capacité à préserver les forêts en
particulier les plus remarquables sera
au cœur d'un one forest Summit qui se
tiendra à Libreville pour regarder
comment accompagner et aider les pays à
ce que des zones qui sont remarquables
en termes de stockage de carbone puisse
être préservée et accompagnée sur la
COP15 la France est à l'origine avec le
Costa Rica d'une coalition qui s'appelle
la Coalition pour une haute ambition
pour la nature et pour les peuples avec
le soutien de beaucoup de ONG ce sont
désormais 112 pays qui font partie de
cette coalition la ligne que nous allons
défendre au Canada c'est la ligne du
30-30 la préservation et la protection
de 30% des terres et de 30% des mers à
l'horizon 2030 et de ce point de vue
comme le secrétaire d'État Hervé
Verville l'a dit tout à l'heure les mots
très forts d'Emmanuel Macron pour
rappeler pour annoncer notre
interdiction d'exploitation des fonds
sous-marins et évidemment un atout en
terme de cohérence et en termes de
conviction pour élargir cette coalition
et défendre une position qui soit
cohérente la question financière elle
est évidemment cruciale la France fait
partie des rares pays qui sont au
rendez-vous de leurs engagement avec les
6 milliards que nous consacrons à ce
sujet merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Vincent cette
linger pour le groupe les républicains
la présidente ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur le Ministre des Solidarités
d'autonomie et des personnes handicapées
monsieur le ministre depuis plusieurs
mois maintenant les EHPAD et plus
généralement l'ensemble des
établissements médico-sociaux sont dans
une situation intenable en plus des
problèmes de recrutement déjà temps
avant le covid ces établissements
souffrent de l'inflation et de la crise
énergétique dans ce contexte leurs
dépenses ont explosé elle pourrait y
faire face en ajustant leurs ressources
via une augmentation du prix de journée
mais ce tarif journalier n'augmente
quasiment pas dans ce contexte de
nombreuses établissements associatifs
sont fortement fragilisés et
enregistrent des sites élevés par
ailleurs plusieurs catégories de
personnels sont toujours exclus du Ségur
certains touchants depuis plusieurs mois
la prime Ségure et d'autres non
ce déséquilibre a pour conséquence
d'instaurer des tensions entre les
salariés alors même qu'un esprit de
solidarité est nécessaire
disons-le clairement durant le covid les
personnels de ces établissements se sont
montrés exemplaires ils n'ont jamais
fait défaut alors qu'ils étaient en
première ligne
dans ma circonscription j'ai rencontré
les salariés des EHPAD myosotis je
Schweitzer et Sainte-Marie ils m'ont
confié leur déception ils ont le
sentiment que leur dévouement n'est pas
reconnu à sa juste valeur alors que
notre pays a connu plusieurs scandales
ces derniers mois dans des EHPAD privés
il est essentiel aujourd'hui de soutenir
très fortement nos EHPAD associatifs
dans ces circonstances monsieur le
ministre quels sont les solutions
quelles sont les mesures que vous
proposez afin de leur venir en aide il y
a urgence monsieur le ministre merci
je vous remercie mon cher collègue la
parole est à Monsieur Jean-Christophe
con ministre de solidarité de
l'autonomie et des personnes handicapées
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
cette linger dès les premiers jours de
mon action j'ai souhaité apporter des
réponses aux difficultés que vous
évoquez et qui concerne de nombreux
EHPAD dans notre pays je serai
d'ailleurs demain dès demain au congrès
de la feae pour discuter de ces sujets
je rappelle qu'aucune majorité avant la
nôtre n'avait autant fait en matière de
revalorisation des salaires dans le
secteur médico-social 12 milliards
d'euros pour l'année 2022 dont 3,2
milliards pour la branche autonomie
c'est 700 000 professionnels qui ont pu
bénéficier d'une augmentation de 183
euros net mensuel je souligne aussi que
je souligne aussi l'extension décidé de
la revalorisation du point d'indice de
la fonction publique au secteur
associatif pour laquelle je me suis
battu pour éviter tout décrochage des
rémunérations j'entends néanmoins les
attentes qui peuvent s'exprimer le
gouvernement poursuit un développeur
constant avec les professionnels mais
ayant en tête que les décisions de
revalorisation ont été prises dans le
contexte de la crise sanitaire et elle
répondait à une logique et ont été
déployés sur des périmètres sur lesquels
il n'est pas prévu de revenir bien sûr
là où elle a cours la négociation
salariale en employeur et employés doit
se poursuivre je considère quant à moi
que l'attractivité des métiers ne se
limite pas aux enjeux de rémunération
elle constitue elle concerne aussi la
qualité de vie au travail les parcours
professionnels la formation autant de
sujets que nous aborderons dans le cadre
du CNR bien vieillir en ce qui concerne
le soutien aux structures en période
d'inflation je rappelle enfin qu'un
dialogue nourrit a lieu avec les
départements au sein du comité des
financeurs pour que chacun puisse
assumer ses responsabilités vis-à-vis
des opérateurs que le gouvernement a
pris ses responsabilités en procédant à
une actualisation exceptionnelle de 440
millions d'euros dans le cadre du plfs
des dotations du secteur médico-social
pour tenir compte de l'inflation et de
la revalorisation du point d'indice et
enfin les structures associatives
figurent dans le décret qui est partout
qui est paru hier pour le bouclier
tarifaire merci monsieur le ministre
monsieur cette lingette oui merci
Monsieur ministre pour ces explications
très claires on voit que vous connaissez
aussi bien les EHPAD que les aides
maternelles merci
la parole est un monsieur Stéphane
delautraite pour le groupe socialiste
merci madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues ma question est celle que tous
les députés de mon groupe auraient voulu
poser à madame la Première ministre
tellement les interpellations des mers
et élus ont été nombreuses depuis le
début de l'année les finances de nos
collectivités sont durement éprouvées
par la situation économique du pays dans
un contexte déjà particulièrement
dégradé composant avec une inflation
galopante les élus ont dû faire face à
la revalorisation certes nécessaires du
point d'indice à la hausse du prix des
dents des alimentaires qui affectent les
cantines à l'augmentation du coût des
matières premières qui pèsent sur les
marchés publics et enfin à la flambée
sans précédent des prix de l'énergie
contrainte à présenter un budget à
l'équilibre de nombreuses collectivités
se retrouvent dans une situation
inextricable ainsi mère et élu locaux
sont souvent démunis et doivent se
résoudre à supprimer une part des
investissements ralentissant de façon
certaine l'activité économique locale ou
bien se résoudre à fermer des services
publics au risque de pénaliser nos
concitoyens les plus modestes s'il est
vrai qu'une partie des communes rurales
bénéficient provisoirement des tarifs
régulés de l'énergie non déplorons que
les autres collectivités souvent
porteuses des équipements structurants
soit exclus du dispositif ainsi aux
côtés des associations d'élus le groupe
socialiste est apparenté apporté avec
constance un engagement un engagement
résolu pour soutenir nos collectivités
en exigeant l'indexation de la DGF sur
l'inflation en maintenant la CVAE qui
contribue au lien fiscal entre
entreprises et territoires en proposant
des temps de Béné des tarifs réglementés
de l'énergie à toutes les collectivités
madame la Première ministre la relation
de confiance entre l'ecta et les
collectivités a été encore une fois
abîmée par la séquence des débats
budgétaires de cet automne après avoir
réintroduit à la hussard dans des
dispositif d'encadrement des dépenses de
fonctionnement des collectivités du type
pacte de Cahors
ministre de la transition écologique et
de la cohésion des territoires
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
députés de la retraite
[Applaudissements]
la Haute Assemblée à être réinterroger
approfondie améliorer pour faire en
sorte d'avoir une réponse qui soit la
plus juste possible par rapport aux
préoccupations et aux besoins des
collectivités et dans le même temps là
aussi de manière exceptionnelle les deux
milliards d'euros du fond d'accélération
sur la transition écologique qui ne sont
pas pris sur les autres crédits vont
permettre d'aller financer des travaux
de rénovation des bâtiments de
changement de l'éclairage de toutes les
mesures qui permettent d'être dépendants
ensuite de ces mêmes énergies fossiles
qui font ensuite grimper la facture donc
on a des aides sur le plan du
fonctionnement avec pour la première
fois depuis 13 ans une augmentent de
dégive qui n'est pas gelée mais qui
réaugmente de plus de 300 millions
d'euros et en parallèle 2 milliards
d'euros de soutien à l'accélération
écologique et 2 milliards et demi pour
les collectivités de plus de 10 employés
pour faire face à la hausse des prix de
l'énergie je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre la parole est à Madame Sarah le
grand pour le groupe
présidente ministre collègues
tu viens de parler de Bolloré tu sais
que tu es dans le groupe Bolloré ici
voici ce qu'un député s'est vu répondre
en direct devant des millions de
téléspectateurs
alors que signifie concrètement être
chez Bolloré chez Bolloré c'est le grand
ménage à chaque acquisition de Canal+ à
Paris Match en passant par iTele et
Europe 1 émission supprimée couverture
imposée départ massifs de journalistes
chez Bolloré c'est un sacré manque
d'autodérision qui conduit à censurer un
livre pour une blague sur le patron à
licencier un humoriste pour une parotide
d'émission c'est un intérêt économique
bien compris et bien défendu on possède
la régie publicitaire donc on coupe les
contrats d'un journal qui a publié une
enquête sur les méfaits de Bolloré en
Afrique c'est en définitive selon les
termes de Bolloré lui-même un combat
civilisationnel on coupe le financement
d'un film qui parle pédocriminalité dans
l'église on réécrit une série qui parle
de laïcité on offre candidat Zemmour la
moitié du temps de parole de TPMP en
période électorale
mais
n'oublions pas non plus les voisins de
paliers de Bolloré car chez Bouygues
chez Niel chez dry aussi on utilise
l'empire médiatique pour défendre des
intérêts économiques et idéologiques
n'oublions surtout pas Bernard Arnault
en voyant son homme demain square
cynique entre un petit journal Picard ce
qui permet à ces quelques hommes de se
sentir totalement chez eux au pays de
l'information c'est l'hyperconcentration
ils sont neufs seulement 9 à détenir 90%
de nos médias madame la Première
ministre vous avez le devoir de garantir
le droit à l'information l'un des
piliers de la démocratie votre
gouvernement compte-t-il agir pour
rendre au peuple ce droit fondamental en
privant les oligarques de leur
toute-puissance
soutiendra-t-il notre proposition loi
pour mettre fin à la concentration des
médias à la main mise de quelques
milliardaires sur nos imaginaires
bravo
la parole est à Monsieur Olivier Véran
ministre délégué chargé du renouveau
démocratique et porte-parole du
gouvernement merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la députée le grain l'objectif du
gouvernement il est très clair c'est
assuré une information libre
indépendante et plus réaliste et notre
méthode c'est celle souhaitée par le
Président de la République et la
première ministre à savoir des étages
généraux de l'information vous avez
déposé effectivement votre groupe à
déposer une une PPL qui est inscrite à
l'ordre du jour du 24 novembre elle
soulève de nombreuses questions parce
que elle aboutirait en particulier nous
semble-t-il un résultat contraire à son
objectif puisqu'elle viendrait
consolider les positions des groupes
déjà en place au détriment de nouveaux
entrants c'est ce que dit d'ailleurs on
s'appuie là-dessus sur un rapport de
l'Inspection Générale qui montrait qu'il
ne fallait pas empêcher les entreprises
ou les chefs d'entreprise de participer
à l'acquisition de groupes de médias de
manière accentuer la diversité et votre
PPL va plutôt dans l'autre sens on est
très intéressé par les travaux de la
commission sénatoriale en la matière la
commission d'enquête je pense notamment
au sénateur socialiste David Assouline
qui en était le rapporteur et qui disait
lui-même que la complexité du sujet
interdit de dégager des solutions
simples et univoques ce message donc du
pluralisme de l'absence de concentration
dans les médias il mérite une
concertation une réflexion approfondie
croyait en la volonté du gouvernement de
la faire aboutir
[Musique]
monsieur le ministre madame
on avait aucune
je vous remercie
et pour terminer la parole est à Madame
Sophie panenacle pour le groupe
Renaissance
merci madame la Présidente
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
secrétaire d'État auprès de la première
ministre chargée de la mer le président
de la République a annoncé à Lisbonne
lors de la conférence des Nations unies
sur l'océan puis à la cop27 l'opposition
de la France à l'exploitation des grands
fonds océaniques notre position est
clairement exprimée la France veut être
à l'avant-garde de la protection de
l'océan et de la biodiversité marine en
haute mer je me réjouis que la
représentation nationale est exprimée à
l'initiative de Nicola Thierry à travers
le projet de résolution invitant le
gouvernement à défendre un moratoire sur
l'exploitation minière des fonds marins
son souhaits de soutenir et d'encourager
notre pays dans cette voie je ne doute
pas que le prochain débat de sur cette
PPR qui s'inscrira dans le cadre d'une
nouvelle niche transpartiza nous
permettra de démontrer notre capacité
d'unité face à un enjeu écologique
majeur monsieur le ministre des députés
de la team maritime étaient à vos côtés
lors de votre intervention des 17e
assises de l'économie de la mer à Lille
le temps fort de l'agenda de l'économie
bleue vous avez fait la démonstration
appréciée par la communauté des gens de
mer que nous nous engageons pour une
économie maritime compétitive et des
carbonées le transport maritime est en
première ligne et doit impérativement
poursuivre sa transition énergétique
vous avez présenté le plan France mer
2030 destiné aux armateurs et aux
propriétaires de navires de commerce de
pêche ou encore de plaisance ils vise à
accélérer la décarbonation du transport
maritime qui a pour objectif le navire 0
émission une telle ambition ne peut se
faire sans investissement dans
l'innovation la formation et surtout
dans la construction par des entreprises
françaises de ces nouveaux navires aussi
pouvez-vous monsieur le ministre nous
assurer des intentions du Gouvernement
pour abonder le fond France mer 2030 et
ainsi assurer le succès de ce dispositif
qui
concré la volonté de la France de
respecter les accords de Paris je vous
remercie je vous remercie la parole est
à Monsieur Hervé Berville secrétaire
d'État chargé de la mer merci madame la
députée mesdames et messieurs les
députés madame la député Sophie
panonacle d'abord je voulais vous
remercier pour votre engagement avec
tous les membres de l'équipe maritime
nous avons comme vous ici au
gouvernement une ambition maritime forte
pour notre pays parce que la mer au fond
répond à deux impératifs l'urgence
écologique avec la protection des océans
et le renforcement de la souveraineté
économique en développant notamment et
bien l'économie maritime partout sur le
territoire et la décarbonation du
transport maritime sur le premier point
la question de l'urgence écologique vous
l'avez dit je l'ai évoqué tout à l'heure
la France a pris une décision courageuse
et décisive courageuse parce que la
France est le deuxième espace maritime
au monde et donc on aurait pu vouloir
tenter de bénéficier de cette
exploitation des fonds marins et puis
elle est décisive parce que nous allons
continuer et bien à convaincre les
autres pays nos partenaires de faire
comme nous d'interdire toute
exploitation minière des grands fonds
marins nous le ferons avec Catherine
Colonna avec Christophe BECHU dans les
différentes instances internationales et
les échéances qui arrivent et puis sur
le deuxième point celui de renforcer la
souveraineté économique dans la lignée
de ce qu'a annoncer la première ministre
sur France nationale j'ai annoncé aux
assises de l'économie de la mer France
mer 2030 France mai 2030 c'est quoi
c'est une stratégie maritime pour notre
pays c'est 10 mois de concertation au
fond pour définir les 10 priorités d'ici
2030 c'est aussi une équipe dédiée au
sein du ministère de la mer pour
accompagner les porteurs de projets pour
accompagner l'innovation partout sur les
territoires notamment sur la
décarbonation et puis c'est une ambition
financière des investissements publics à
hauteur de 300 millions d'euros minimum
d'ici la fin du quinquennat pour partout
accélérer la décarbonation du transport
maritime notamment flotte de pêche
flotte de commerce plaisance donc vous
le voyez notre ambition maritime elle
est sur deux piliers la préservation de
la biodiversité marine et en même temps
pourtant la décarbonation de ce
magnifique secteur qui est pourvoyeur
d'emploi et nous aurons là aussi une
action forte sur la formation et
l'attractivité des métiers nous
continuons et nous irons avec un
objectif fort d'ici 2030 merci je vous
remercie monsieur le ministre la séance
de questions au Gouvernement est
terminée la séance est suspendue